call session to order
please and and uh Mr whimet um what we'd
like to do if possible is to go over the
questions if you can just do the best
you can to answer what we got and tell
us where you're at even if you don't
great good morning uh good morning sir
for the record my name is name is Mike
whims I serve as director of the waste
management division for the New
Hampshire Department of Environmental
Services um I'm joined this morning by
our assistant director Sarah Kern and uh
happy to uh be before you to try to
answer some of your questions I I as the
committee knows these questions were
provided late last week and um in order
to really try to address them in a
holistic fashion I prepared some remarks
I also have some introductory remarks
that I think will be
important for the sub commit to he and
would be of interest so i' like proceed
with those if that works um so uh Dees
has been working in Earnest on updates
to the solid waste rules and as this
committee knows we've been engaged in a
process of drafting chapter 800 Solid
Waste rules that lay out the design
construction and operating requirements
for landfills for about one year now uh
that process has involved robust public
involvement including several uh public
listening sessions and informal comment
periods um for the waste management
division the first step in the formal
rulem Maring process begins with
presentation of its proposed rules to
the New Hampshire Waste Management
Council and that's prior to filing a
rulemaking notice under the
administrative procedures act the
enabling law is RSA 2109 that
establishes the New Hampshire Waste
Management Council and it provides that
the council has three important roles
the first is to consult with and advise
the director on the division's programs
and operations the second is to hear all
administrative appeals of the department
uh of Department decisions that are
administered by the division and the
third is to review and weigh in on
administrative rules proposed by the
division and under the statute uh the
division presents its proposed rules to
the council and the council has 15 days
to present any objections to the
proposed rule if the council objects to
a rule the commissioner May adopt the
rule only after presenting a written
reply to the council detailing the
reasons for adopting the rule over its
objections and in keeping with those
requirements on January 18th um the
division appeared before the waste
council at its January meeting and uh we
presented draft initial proposals for
chapters 100 regarding definitions
chapter 300 regarding permitting and
then chapter 800 on the the landfill
requirements during that meeting we
heard many questions from the council
expressing concerns about the potential
impacts of the rules particularly with
respect to chapter 800 and in the weeks
immediately following that presentation
we received substantive comments and
requests to meet from both public and
private members of the regulated
community so
specifically excuse me we met with
representatives of the anders skogen
Valley Regional Refuge disposal District
which operates the mount carbury
landfill and success um the waste
management of New Hampshire um which
operates the turnkey landfill in
Rochester cassella waste system which
operates the ncees landfill in Bethlehem
and resource Waste Services which is a
company that processes cndd materials in
eeping and Salem New Hampshire uh they
express significant concerns about the
Draft rules and their potential impact
on future expansion development and
operation of solid waste landfills and
Associated cost impacts we consider
these concerns and in some areas we
determined that there were appropriate
changes to the draft proposal that
should be made so we did that and we
returned to the council at its February
meeting on February 15th to present a
revised draft proposal and that's a copy
of which has been provided to this
subcommittee and it is a track changes
copy so it shows what changed from
January 18th through the 15th of
February and at that meeting the council
took public comment from industry
Representatives expressing many of these
aformentioned concerns that I just
outlined as a result of this the council
decided to schedule a special meeting
one week later on February 21st to
further discuss the rules immediately
prior to that meeting the council was
presented with a letter from attorneys
representing waste management New
Hampshire Inc which outlined um the
company's concerns about the February
15th Draft rules during the meeting each
counselor and attendance expressed
significant concerns about the potential
impacts of the proposed rules including
their concerns that the rules would make
it too difficult to expand existing
landfills or to site new landfills would
unne necessarily increase construction
and operational costs of landfills and
would drive up disposal costs burdening
citizens municipalities and the New
Hampshire business Community during the
meeting the council decided to draft a
letter to Dees conveying its comments
that letter was which was issued to
commissioner Scott and to me and dated
February 23rd outlined the council's
concerns and urg Dees to reopt the
currently existing chapter 800 rules as
they exist today and in order to provide
time to further engage the public and
stakeholders in review of the proposed
rules the council also appended the
waste management in New Hampshire letter
to its letter asking Dees to address its
expressed concerns so upon review of the
council's letter Dees has elected to
consider further additions revisions to
the draft proposal and present them to
the council at its March meeting SCH
which is now scheduled for Thursday
March 21st thereafter we would expect to
begin the formal rulemaking process by
requesting a fiscal impact statement
from the legislative budget assistant
and following its receipt we would file
a rulemaking notice with the office of
legislative Services now this will
likely result in a minor delay in filing
the final proposal for these rules and
so and and therefore adopting the final
rule to a date that's beyond the J July
1 deadline that we're working under
however um I've been it's been made
clear to me that by filing our proposal
prior to the deadline Dees will ensure
that the exist existing rules will
remain in effect until the final rule is
adopted and that would likely occur
sometime depending on the jail cars
schedule and other things that aren't
entirely in our control sometime between
July and September of this year Dees is
confident that the proposed rules that
will be filed will be superior in every
respect to the existing rules they will
be more protective of the environment
and human health and they have been
modernized to acknowledge and reflect
advances in technology and the state of
the practice of landfill design
construction and operation they will
reflect the collective experiences and
learning of our permitting and
compliance staff over the last 10 or so
years relative to the types of problems
that we see at landfills and how those
problems can be addressed through
improved rules they will put our
landfill permitting and compliance
monitoring programs on firmer and
Sounder footing to make sure that the
design construction and operational
landfills moving forward is safer and
more
sustainable I note that we will remain
on our plan schedule with respect to the
chapter 100 definitions Rule and the
chapter 300 permitting rules the initial
proposals for those chapters have been
provided to the LBA along with the
request for a fiscal impact statement so
the formal rulemaking process for those
chapters has begun and we'll be filing
rulle making notices and scheduling
public hearings for those rules in the
coming weeks with that if there are any
questions regarding what I presented uh
I'd be happy to take them now um before
we begin reviewing the list of questions
that were provided by the subcommittee
representative
Penza first I'd like to talk about the
waste management Council So currently um
it is I would say probably about 90%
lopsided so you have um you know public
interest which you would see that that
would be the most important position to
have in there that's the voice of the
public right that's vacant um the other
uh one two three four five members are
either employed by um um companies that
are employed by either waste management
or cassella or the others so the
industry um public health expert vacant
municipal office
vacant uh the only there's only one
elected official which is a gentleman
from gtown the other office is vacant
business of financial Community vacant
so how are we having this Council direct
this process when it is not
topic it's certainly true that the
council has suffered from vacancies for
a number of years um I I couldn't I'm
not going to offer an opinion on on that
that the law is very clear that the
council has a key um specific role in
our rulemaking and we of course observe
that role as we proceed with our
rulemaking activities one question does
de assign appoint or control who's on
the council no those government those
those appointments are made by the
governor and Council okay and is Dees
required to go to the council in its
current format to get approval of what
they do absolutely okay well and again
approval is a strong word um they
guidance guidance and feed the specific
role is outlined very clearly in the
statute and we we we are required to um
you know the the most I think important
thing is we know that whenever we're
going to do a rulemaking the very first
step in beginning that formal rulemaking
process is presenting that initial
proposal to the council but you do not
control who's on the council we do not
okay thank
you representative H Haskins thank you
very much good morning good morning
so I don't know much about this and you
know this is my first term so I'm
learning how all the agencies work
together but to representative penza's
point this undermines public confidence
and that's one of the issues that we're
dealing with with the fact that these
vacancies have happened over years and
haven't been
addressed puts the public in the back
seat when it comes to how the process is
set up and as we go forward and want to
work together we represent the public so
you can see why those vacancies for
public health and for um whatever the
other one was uh public interest public
anything you can see why that undermines
public confidence do you agree or do you
understand I'm I understand your remarks
I'm not going to comment or disparage
the the council as is currently comp
well yeah I don't intend to disparage
them I just intend to reference the fact
that this is the result and so as we go
forward representing the public we want
their voices through us to be heard
okay so let me let me propose this so
first of
all Mr wimon has nothing to do with the
way Council rather than he reps to them
well but that this whole line of
discussion what I would recommend is
that we allow de to go through the
questions that we
asked once we go through those we only
have 50 minutes left before we have
another
session and so if we can allow them to
go through that and then we'll pursue
questions from there cuz we could talk
around this for next 50 minutes and get
nothing done but it but I'm not going to
talk about the specifically with the
council he he made reference to the
council he made reference to going to
the council saying that the rules were
too restrictive and then they weakened
the rules and so that that's the line of
questioning I want to move forward on
that I don't need to we don't need to
beat a dead horse about the council I I
think then he proceeded to say about you
know with protection and all these types
of things my next line of question
literally has to do with the ru the
rules being weakened okay well those are
the questions we ask them in the form
very spec very specifically and so let
them answer the questions okay and then
we'll see where we go from there okay
because we've asked those
questions sir over to you thank you Mr
chair uh so when we appeared before the
subcommittee back in October members
expressed an interest in providing a
list of questions as I indicated earlier
uh we did receive those questions um
last Friday and um we've reviewed them
and in order to address them in a
holistic fashion we kind of grouped and
organized them under several topic
headings which we'll address now um and
then certainly be willing to field any
questions that follow the first uh
category was really just an individual
question regarding uh requirements for
municipal notification in the event of
some kind of a incident or release at a
landfill and um uh there are certain
notifications of applications that you
know that need to be made to
municipalities regarding the filing of
applications and such but there's
currently no specific requirement in the
rule to notify municipalities of
incidents um the rules that regard
incident notification at any solid waste
facility be it a landfill or another
type are embodied in chapter 1000 which
is a rule making we've already completed
however um we think it it's it's a fair
question we think it's something that we
could address in future revisions to
1,000 1,000 doesn't expire for 10 years
but that doesn't mean we can't start
rulemaking on it next year or next week
it's we we we often go in we don't you
readopm in between that time to make
desired changes so that's something that
we would consider in the meantime Dees
will include provision for notification
municipalities um about incidents
release incidents and copying them on
correspondence related to those
incidents in our operating procedures so
that's something that you know I think
we can make happen in the absence of of
an immediate rule change um the second
cat take one at a time sure absolutely
it's a pleasure of the committee
absolutely go ahead thank you Mr chair
and and thank you for that I I do
appreciate the Insight around um you
know guidance um do you anticipate going
through Jael car and requesting an
administrative rule change preemptively
within the 10
years I mean I I think possibility it's
fair to say that we are engaged in Ru
making on a pretty full-time basis I
mean we we if we were to only amend our
rules every 10 years um there would be a
lot of things that would be left undone
we often receive directives from the
legislature to address certain things so
we go to rule making for those things um
and and we will be we will undoubtedly
be doing additional rulemakings in the
coming months and years um regarding uh
you know outside the need the need to
reopt um so we'll have an opportunity to
do that and I think that's a fair
request okay thank you uh the second
category is regarding sighting
stringency and uh the subcommittee had
requested a demonstration that the
proposed sighting rules um to
demonstrate that the arguments by the
industry that the rules are too
stringent and excessively eliminate
sites from consideration um you know to
provide some proof of that um as as
we've noted the industry has expressed
concerns that the proposed sighting
criteria are so stringent as to
effectively eliminate most potential
future landfill sites and potential
areas of expansion of existing landfill
sites from eligibility and again the
committee has asked for for proof of
that um I have to say it's unlikely we
would be able to obtain a document or
documents that would Pro provide the
desired level of proof um it's also been
requested I think one of the things that
the subcommittee asked for was a map
showing what sites in the state would be
ineligible as a result of the rules that
are being proposed um and um I don't
believe anyone is going to be able to
produce such a map we certainly don't
have that um in our discussions with
members of the industry they have
indicated that they have conducted
reviews of available sites and have
concluded that there already exist very
few eligible sites even under existing
sighting criteria um Dees does not
possess any of these data reports
they're they're not public documents and
the industry is not offered to share
them with us um we're aware that many
different site criteria must be met for
a given parcel to be practicable for to
site landfill these include uh among
other things Geographic size and
location permissible zoning proximity to
adequate Transportation routes
availability and proximity of suitable
Aggregate and and Sand and Gravel
materials conformance with Dees sighting
criteria relative to Wetlands surface
water drinking water sources and
neighboring features and land uses as
well as of course the site geology and
when all these criteria can be met the
site must also be available for
acquisition by the by the by the by the
person who's interested in citing a
landfill so you can imagine that it's
not easy to find a site that checks all
those boxes um the concerns expressed
Center largely on observations by the
industry that the geology of the large
sites needed for landfills is unlikely
to be 100% homogeneous it's not going to
be all um consistent and that as
originally proposed the rules that the
agency proposed um that specifi site
soil conditions were so stringent as to
effectively elim minate most potential
landfill sites and preclude expansion of
our existing landfill sites um while we
don't possess the specific reports on
this topic or a map uh we do employ at
least 25 experienced hydrogeologists
whose Collective knowledge and field
experience support the assertion that
New Hampshire's geology is heterogeneous
uh during their careers these
professionals have sat on drill Rigs and
logged countless borings into the into
the Earth that demonstrate this in
addition in their work at Dees
these staff collectively review hundreds
of site assessment reports and boring
logs each year that confirm that the
geology of most sites even on a small
scale was not homogeneous so this uh the
concern is that the way that we
originally proposed the
rules you know read in their strictest
context um they would basically create a
situation where even the existing
landfills that have been cited and have
been operating safely um would not be
able to expand because they wouldn't
meet those requirements so we um this is
an area where we realized we probably
overshot the runway a little bit um you
know no no ill intent in any direction
on our part but um we we did go back and
look at that and try to determine what
would be continue to be a protective
standard that would not kind of break
the system if you will so that's how how
we address
that represent
Penza okay so let's go to that let's go
to the protective standard so on January
31st we brought up how Maine has um
their landfill sightings is 10 to the5
um quoting you from that you said I
would seriously doubt that landfills
cited and operate in Maine right now
meet a 10 to the five standard I mean
it's very unlikely that's your quote so
um this is specifically from Maine if
you'd like to know their Criterion um
it's 10 to the5 I can give you their um
you know hydraulic conductivity D all of
that so and they have an active landfill
from the same person that you have a
permanent right now that is working
underneath those um those Criterion so
we have a neighboring state that's that
how about let's go to um Mississippi
they're 110 to the6 Vermont 110 to the4
but there's a ton of Criterion in there
Arkansas 110 to the7 Colorado 110 --6
Missouri 1105 Ohio 110 the5 California
110 the6 I can go on and on but you're
getting the idea we are actually going
down a road of making us um in a sense
kind of the dumbest state for for um for
our 10 in the neg3 so it just doesn't
make sense if you look at the change the
last change in the rules is about
500 times weaker than the one prior to
if you look at um the landfill in Berlin
which is on Clay they are right now at
uh conductivity of about one foot per
year based upon the rules right now it
would be 15 feet per day and then
because we put the average in there it
could be a certain part of the landfill
could be almost 100 feet 150 feet per
day that's what we're looking at there's
no way in in any explanation that you
could say that 10 to the neg3 is
protective at all I don't understand
this
so This touches on another area one of
the area groupings that we had was the
comparison to other states rules and I I
would like to say a little bit about
that and then we could talk more
specifically to your questions um the
com the committee has expressed concerns
and specifically that the rules don't
align with the state of mains rules and
uh as we've expressed in Prior meetings
um we don't believe that direct
comparison to other states rules is
appropriate or or productive for a
couple of key reasons first other states
law and policy directives are different
all states administrative rules are
derived from enabling state laws that
Grant rulle making Authority and shape
the nature and content of those rules
without an understanding of the state
specific legislative policy directives a
direct comparison of specific rules is
not meaningful for example the states of
Connecticut and Massachusetts have
implemented policies that have made
development and operation of instate
Solid Waste facilities so difficult that
each state now lacks capacity for much
if not all of its waste and consequently
those states must rely on extensive use
of out ofate facilities for disposal of
their own waste New Hampshire law does
not provide such a directive on the
contrary it uh explicitly directs and
this is a quote from the statute that we
must ensure that adequate capacity
exists within the state to accommodate
the solid waste generators generated
within the borders of the state now the
second reason is that even if you assume
that an overarch the overarching policy
directives are aligned between two
states uh a fair comparison between spe
two specific rules cannot be made that
is the comparison is Apples oranges and
I think this goes to a lot of the
statistics that you just read
representative Potenza so when reviewing
other states rules individual Provisions
have to be taken in the context of the
entire rule framework which requires
significant experience with a particular
rule set our experience with this as
prompted by several prior comparisons
with the state of Main's rules have
Illustrated this issues this issue when
we attempt to dig into the details uh we
find that the context for how the rule
is implemented within that State's
framework indicates that it cannot be
directly compared with a seemingly
analogous New Hampshire rule so
accordingly we're not inclined to engage
in specific debate on this topic because
we don't possess an in-depth knowledge
of other state rule sets and it's
neither productive nor helpful now
specifically to the to the hydraulic
conductivities that you just cited
without a very specific understanding of
what is being required there which soils
are being referenced and also what the
liner requirements are a lot of states
that may have a 10 Theus 6 or a 10us 7th
requirement are basically talking about
in many cases a single line facility
that's required to have a clay layer and
natural or or or an imp placed clay
layer beneath it that is a way to to
construct the landfill and that kind of
a landfill can be constructed in New
Hampshire but um what we encourage and
what our rules encourage is that we use
the most sophisticated engineered
systems for these facilities as possible
and that's what the industry without
exception has elected to do and they
construct double line systems engineered
double line systems that have double
line geosynthetic liners
um that uh basically we believe and and
the industry I think is born out provide
a much Superior level of protection
we're aware that these 10us 6 and 10us
7th impl clay layers um while they may
be um uh put in place and and appear to
provide a significant level of
protection um they also present very
specific stability issues because those
kinds of soils while they have low
hydraulic conductivity are not
particularly you effective for for
building on and even when they are done
properly and and placed and remain
stable they can develop cracks that can
basically so you can imagine you have a
very low conductivity layer of clay and
then it develops desiccation cracks that
provide a direct fracture route from a
leak in the liner to in a single liner
in many cases down to the formation so
there are lots of reasons why those kind
that's that's an example of why those
kinds of comparison
are not meaningful and again we we're
going to be reluctant to engage in a
state-by-state review because it's just
not we we're we're expert in our rules
and that's where it begins and ends we
are not experts in any other State's
rules um represent
hton thank
you I'm back to my public confidence
because somehow this is the piece that I
feel most strongly about pardon me so
the industry says um they can't expand
they can't build new sites unless they
have what they
want there's no evidence they don't give
us any evidence there's
share how am I supposed to have how are
we supposed to have confidence that
other scientists who are weighing in and
I think you know are um schooling some
of
us believe that citing a landfill in
sand because there's a lot of sand
available makes no sense and I I agree
with everything rep Pensa said you know
it's gotten from October to December to
January weaker each
time I don't feel good about that and as
as I represent the people who want to
know what I'm doing about it I have to
register the fact that I think it's
rulemaking thank you um Mr chair and
thank you for taking my I'm sorry was
sorry um thank you Mr chair um thank you
uh director whimet can you um speak to I
I we've talked about it a couple of
times with regard to site design
tolerances versus Institue design
tolerances
and
why we have a discrepancy there in uh
going with a less tolerant number in one
circumstance versus another why are they
not the
same when you're looking at the
tolerances yeah and I and actually I
think it might be helpful if I review a
few other sections because I touch on
all of those things and then we can if
you if I don't address it well you by by
me so I just want to be clear I'm not
asking for you know New Hampshire to
mirror other states I mean I think it's
clear the original rules that came out
that we have in place they're already a
thousand times weaker at least than 10
other states that are citing right now
that's what I'm saying it's not about
compar and this and land and all of that
I mean we know the science is is is
clear I like to ask the question how
long have you been in the position that
you've been in at Dees since 2007 okay
have you done rules
yet since you've been there have have
you written rules we have implemented
countless rules time citing land site
rules representative Penza we're going
to we're going to stick to the rules
that they're this is about this isn't
about resumes and everything it isn't
about they asking we're not do it oh my
gosh I'm just making a point have we
haven't done this right because it these
rules have been in place for what 19
years 20
years the rules were reopt 10 years ago
10 years ago and there were changes made
to the citing criteria correct but like
this full whole process hasn't happened
for they it's been in place for 20 years
right
1920 you have to look at each individual
rules some rules are older some are
newer again we we make changes to rules
bit by bit in many cases I'm talking
about citing
landfills there have been changes to
citing criteria that were made I believe
back in the
2014 um rule making okay thank
you so um the next category that we had
identified was um the citing
requirements applicability and this this
is a simple one so the subcommittee had
Express concerns that citing
requirements do not apply to the
expansion of existing facilities and
that's a misunderstanding of the
proposed rules the sighting requirements
while they're not retroactive to
existing permited Footprints uh do
indeed apply to the Future expansion of
existing
facilities um so then um moving on to
the hydraulic cont conductivity of soils
issue the subcommittee had expressed
concerns regarding the requirements
surrounding hydraulic conductivity of
both insitu soils and imp placed
engineered soils in locations both under
and outside the footprint of the
landfill so there are two categories of
soil that are important to landfill
sighting and construction the first is
the insitu natural soils that exist at
the site and the second is what may be
referred to as engineered soils that may
be mined from the site or brought in
from offsite the first type insitu soils
are specified in our landfill sighting
requirements the draft uh that you have
before you which represents the February
15th uh um version um uh specifies that
insitu soils beneath the footprint of
the landfill have an average average
hydraulic saturated hydraulic
conductivity of 5 x 10us 3 cm/s or less
which would be typical of a fine sand or
a silty sand the idea behind this rule
is to ensure that landfills are not
sighted in locations with soils with
high values of Hy hydraulic conductivity
as as some coar Sands or gravels might
exhibit um the second type the
engineered soils are soils that are
selected and in place during the
construction process these soils are
important because their specifications
and the manner of their installation can
be carefully controlled they are of
require they're required to be of lower
hydraulic conductivity than the
specifications applicable to the insitu
soils and because they're installed
their consistency and homogeneity can be
in assured they immediately underly the
liner system and they form the first
liner defense in the event of a liner
system failure the rules before you
specify that this bedding layer shall
consist of soils with a saturated
hydraulic conductivity of 1 time 10-4
cm/ second or less which would be
typical of a silty sand a silt or a
coarse glacial
till um also require that they have no
Stones greater than an inch in diameter
and be compacted in accordance with
established engineering and ASM
standards this is all to ensure that a
stable and low permeability bedding
layer is constructed um for for support
of the engineer double liner system and
I would note that liner system um the
specific are consistent with liner
systems under the federal rules for
haard Waste landfills so they're very
high speec um protective liner system
that we require and that is indeed built
uh designed and constructed here in New
Hampshire at our
landfills so I I can break here if if
you'd like to further ask about
that uh thank you I think in our
previous discussions we had talked about
engineered double liners and then we
also talked about the potential of a
third clay liner right right is that
something that we are still
considering that that's not something
that has been um put into the rules um
we are concerned that um there there are
some constructibility issues associated
with Clay there's availability of
materials that can be an issue um and
then um for the reasons that I described
earlier sometimes you actually end up it
it's possible you could very carefully
in place a clay layer as a triple
protection
um put it in there construct the
landfill and then because keep in mind
this the rules also require that the 6
ft below the bottom liner be unsaturated
has to be have to be above the water
table so that clay layer Clays are most
effective and in in terms of low
hydraulic conductivity when they're
moistened and so but by sighting that
kind of a layer in an area that is
designed to be above the water table
even if you do a great job installing it
what the industry has found and what
what other states have found is that in
some cases these desiccation cracks
develop and you end up with actually
something that would be much worse and
much less protective than just a tight
even just a 10 the minus three soil um
it would actually be convey
contamination in the event of a liner
leak more quickly than a silty sand say
or or a or a fine
sand and while we're talking about water
tables and given um sort of
environmental changes that we are seeing
with you know
um water levels rising in some places um
I'm assuming that those are also factors
that you all are taking into account
when you're having these conversations
around the
rules yes and when you when you site
either a new landfill or an expansion of
an existing landfill one of the key
challenges is to ensure that you have
that six Fe of Separation um to be
candid obviously landfills are not in a
charitable business they want to Max
maximize their their uh their capacity
to uh to accept waste and so they're not
looking they're looking to meet the
standard but they're not looking to sort
of gratuitously put another couple of
feet of unsaturated soil in there to be
safe they're going to meet the standard
that's what they're going to meet so
they have to work very hard to make sure
that they demonstrate to the agency that
they're going to meet that that six feet
of Separation distance and and we hold
that so going back to the um the
statement in regards with sand and stuff
so um so fine sand maybe close to five
times negative to the neg3 but Dees has
now allowed it um to be average which
means the substantial Parts um of the
site can be pure
gravel no that's I don't think that's a
a fair statement um what what that
recognizes is that it goes back to that
issue of homogeneity um and the the idea
that um I mean it's been suggested some
people suggested take a bunch of
readings and the most conductive area of
the site is then declared to be
representative of the site and that's
not true either so what I think um we
were hearing is that if there isn't some
opportunity to look at a representative
average of the formation which we can
use our hydrogeologists to to ensure
that that is done in a workmanlike and
in in a defensible way um then you could
have a situation where one sample of a
lens of more conductive material would
eliminate an entire site candidly in a
way that's unfair and then not really
not doesn't really make sense and so
that's what we were hearing again I I
want to emphasize when we heard these
comments and concerns from the industry
we really dug in and we listened to what
they were saying and we went back and
looked at it we've not made all the
changes they requested by any measure um
and but but we did realize that we made
some errors when we when we first
proposed the rules and there were some
areas where we were going to have
probably unintended consequences that
nobody wanted that the agency didn't
want it that the public doesn't want and
certainly that the industry didn't want
and those are the areas where we've
elected to make changes in order to
address those errors and that's you know
I think that's the most plain way that I
I I can deliver the rest of my remarks
in probably five minutes or less that's
if that's
helpful
okay sure so um the next area that we
was was some questions that centered
around what I think really amounts to do
the rules consider climate change and
the and and the clear answer to that is
yes and as I stated in my introductory
remarks these proposed rules reflect the
collective experiences and learning of
our staff
um and the and and particularly relative
to the kinds of problems that we see at
landfills and among these problems are
the impacts of increased frequency
intensity of rainfall events and
temperature changes that lead to
increased freeze th thaw cycling these
are not prospective events we've been
witnessing them for several years now
these proposed rules include changes to
sighting criteria and storm water and
leech a management rules that reflect an
attempt to address actual operational
problems that we're W witnessing at
landfills the changes are intended to
account for and effectively manage these
intensified events to ensure that
landfills can continue to be operated
safely and protectively as our climate
continues to change examples of changes
include uh requiring lee8 collection and
removal systems to be designed for the
25-year storm plus an additional 20%
this accounts for additional
precipitation associated with more
intense storm events and also for snow
melt um infiltration also the storm
Water Management Systems including storm
stor water detention ponds will be
required to be designed and constructed
to handle 50e storms uh where previously
the standard was 25e
this uh no was two different categories
so so the first one was um
regarding
um uh leate collection and removal
systems for those they have to be
designed to the 25 years storm that's Al
always been true but then we've added a
requirement that you you calculate what
the 25e storm is and then add 20% and
you designed to that
standard Murray thank you uh Mr chair
and thank you for taking my question um
with regard to the 50-year storm
preparation there are other places in
which we see a 100-year storm
preparation so um throughout the state
planning of various other infrastructure
sure can you explain the reason for
choosing a 50 years storm yeah and then
part parts of that there are parts of
our rules that also require design for
100-year storm and it's for different
components of the system and a lot of it
centers on you know what is the role of
that particular system and what happens
if it's over toau what's the consequence
if it if it's if its capacity is
exceeded one of the issues you know
everybody can say well why don't you
just design everything for the 500e
storm and and the problem with that is
is that then you you end up with
physical um manifestations that you
would not have imagine I mean if if
somebody designed a a highway or a
culvert for a 500-year storm you'd have
to drive up over it you order you know
it would be so huge so so a lot of them
are practical design considerations and
and everything is offsetting right so
you you design a particular system for a
certain flow needs to be a certain size
and how it's constructed and the space
it takes up has impacts on other systems
so the rules really reflect a balancing
of those considerations balancing risk
and and really trying to I know for
examp example you know we we proposed
that sighting of landfills which used to
be 100e storm 100e flood plane is now
500e flood plane sorry um sorry it it
used to be 100e flood plane now it's
500e flood plane so as you can imagine
that's a you know the landfill is going
to be there forever you want to make
sure that you're really looking at a
sighting that is not going to run into a
problem even the event of a very uh you
know rare storm so I hope that addresses
your question thank you so then the next
area is uh time travel considerations
the subcommittee expressed a belief that
language relating to ensuring that leaks
or failures could be detected and
remediated prior to contamination
reaching nearby surface water had been
deleted and also expressed a desire for
a specific time of travel to be
identified in the rule so on the first
issue uh the subcommittee questioned why
the provisions of specifically enw
843c had been deleted and in fact this
section was not deleted but rather was
strengthened by adding additional Lang
language within that section and then
reorganizing and removing the struck
language to section 80403 H so that's a
little in the weeds but but that
language none of that language has been
deleted it's just been reorganized and
and moved um and I would argue
strengthened as well with the additional
language and then as to establishing a
specific numerical time of travel
standard as we've discussed previously
with a subcommittee we believe that
proposed numerical setbacks setback
distances in feet are protective and
provide a simpler standard that's easier
to administer and enforce and much less
susceptible to
appeal um and then the next category is
the ownership of landfill infrastructure
and that was with regard to footprint
land leech a handling and Roads the
subcommittee asked several questions
regard related to the requirement that
landfill property be owned by the permit
e and the subcommittee also asked DS to
clarify that the landfill um includes
infrastructure like tanks and lagoons
which I presume it refers to storm water
detention ponds um the answer is yes
these are considered to be included in
the definition of facility and that
that's actually a statutory definition
that stems right from the statute um the
committee also asked if this applies to
private roads that provide access to the
site this is a topic that's been called
into question relative to a permit
application that is currently pending
before the department so it would not be
appropriate for the Department to
comment on that topic at this time and
then lastly the last group that we
categorize the questions into was
requests to consider additions of
certain Concepts to the rules the
subcommittee asked about the
Department's interest in considering
several additional Concepts or rule
Provisions
um and uh first of all the subcommittee
asked if a rule could be added requiring
an applicant to hire an independent
hydrogeologist to estimate seepage
velocity at the site and calculate a
5-year distance of travel this was the
subject of the of some previous failed
legislation
thees doesn't believe it could impose
such a rule without a change in the law
the subcommittee also asked several
other questions regarding imposing
alternate soil requirements required
hydraulic conductivity standards and
specific setback distances we believe
that our proposed sighting Criterion
setbacks uh will be appropriate and
protective and um sub committee also
asked if sighting criteria could be
amended to include requirements that any
new landfills be cited not closer than
30 miles from a super fund site or from
another landfill and we don't see any
basis uh for such requirements we knowe
that there are over 300 closed landfills
in the state and if that were
implemented as proposed it probably
would eliminate the entire state from
consideration for landfill sighting um
and that that concludes our review of
the topics and we're happy to further
questions thank you any um and can you
provide that your written testimony is
that possible sure I can I can I can
email the the committee of copy when I
get back to the office than and
represent Murray than you I do have a
couple of questions to the uh redlined
striketh through changes um one of them
I did have was with regard to the I
guess the
re the addition on page four about um
level one and two perennial streams in
the you say page four you mean the
commit of the draft of your of the draft
okay Council draft let me uh
that I'm sorry could you repeat the
question it yes it was around um the
conversation about level one and two
perennial streams I believe um and it
looks like initially it said any
perennial stream and now there's a
conversation about level one and two
perennial streams so can you speak to
the rationale around that sure yeah what
we learned is that that that's probably
an area where we uh with good intent
mention we probably overshot the runway
a little bit um if you look at you know
the um the lay of the land in New
Hampshire there are um On Any Given site
on larger sites that might be likely
potential candidates for landfills they
are likely to be very small um initial
first and second order streams that um
would would basically potentially be
impacted and um uh if you impose the um
the 500 foot the new 500 foot setback
would probably eliminate many many sites
and make it very difficult to sight a
landfill and so we from a practical
standpoint we realized that we could
draw a distinction between those and
other more substantial streams so we
continue with the 500 foot for the other
perennial streams but for the first and
second order streams we propos to revert
to the original existing standard of 200
feet
okay what I'd like to do is um s if you
could just uh stick around and if we got
a little more time more questions but
I'd like to get Mr Podi up here as I did
you
good morning good morning and welcome I
just wanted to publicly thank you for
inviting us down to take a look at the
waste management site on the 5ifth
looking forward to it happy to have you
there yeah I think that'll be a
worthwhile trip for whoever's willing to
come um I understand DS will be there I
think that's great as well um give folks
an opportunity to ask questions and
discuss the site and just generally what
we do as a company and what some of the
challenges we have um um you know in the
industry so looking forward to it great
and I I mean my
question first of all is what is your
opinion of the process and the progress
of the ru making from an industry
perspective okay um just from a history
standpoint I've um I've been in New
Hampshire doing what I'm doing now for
over 30 years have worked with Dees
throughout that period of time in a
engineering compliance role and
currently uh in an operations role if
you will um my experience the the dees
does a great job uh in the task that's
in front of them uh historically uh the
rules you know are updated every 10
years or so and I've been involved uh in
some capacity in those prior
reviews and in the past we've had
meetings years ago with Dees folks in
the industry and folks that were not in
the industry going through issues
changes concerns and those were all
considered currently um I think the
process that's being done now is a
little cumbersome but I understand uh
there's folks that are on either side of
the table looking at the rules that are
currently in place and wanting changes
to be made um we have worked through the
change through the changes but also
through the rules that are currently in
place and have been able to you know de
velop the turnkey facility and keep that
operational I will tell you it hasn't
been easy with under the existing rules
I do believe that the proposed changes
as originally uh issued would make it
extremely difficult uh to build out what
was currently permitted at that site uh
We've expressed some of those concerns
and some of the nuances and the rules
and how we would interpret those um with
the dees they understood the concerns
we've had they've made some of the Chang
changes they haven't made other changes
um I will tell you I don't envy the
position that Dees is in because I know
they're hearing concerns and both side
of the table and I think they're doing a
great job I think director whims did an
excellent job this morning really
summarizing the process and what you
know has gone on uh so I appreciate you
know his willingness to at least listen
to us even though you know they're not
taking everything that we've requested
under consideration I understand that to
be the case so understood
okay any any
questions
nope from your perspective in dealing
with uh this issue overall are there any
glaring areas that are going to break
our waste management
system I I don't I can't point to one
specific item I think it's accumulation
of changes that will um make go going
forward extremely challenging uh for us
and likely for others um you know we've
looked at the property that we have out
in Rochester currently what we own uh
there is some limited capacity there to
continue beyond the 23 for permanent
sight life um under the current rules
under the new rules um I think it's
going to be really limited if we can
continue to operate beyond that period
of time um setback criteria sub surface
conditions um you know limitations on
vertical expansions a number of
different things would you know
accumulate to Mak uh continue to operate
that site Beyond 20 34
challenge um in fact there was an
article on the front page of the
fosterers yesterday citing this I've had
conversations um with the city and they
they've expressed some concern um but I
said you know it is what it is we'll do
the best we can but uh I can't guarantee
that will be operational after
2034 okay and
um advice to this committee as
we try to look at exactly protecting our
environment protecting and preventing
things that have happened in the past
while allowing for a requirement for the
state to have uh Waste Management
facilities
um what would is there anything that
we're not looking at that we should be
looking at I mean from a from a rule
standpoint I would just recommend that
you know the process that was outlined
by director wisat this morning continue
to move forward um you know that those
rules will come out for public comment
um they'll have additional comments that
get submitted um and it'll go through
that process I I I think they'll be um
better from our perspective from what
initially was submitted um it won't be
where they're at for the you know
relative to the rules that are in place
today but um I don't know if I would
recommend any changes at this point uh
there's been a awful lot of work by uh
Dees and their staff to work through the
rules and make the changes um that folks
have presented to them on both sides of
the table so I at this point I don't
think there's anything that I would you
know change at this point I mean keeping
the existing rules in place would be
great we've been able to work through
those but I know that
uh there's pressure to make those
changes or make some changes and I I
think this state has heard those
concerns and are making changes to try
to address those issues that have been
presented so and and representative H
Haskins representative Penza have
brought up quite a few questions really
it's about public
confidence and um clearly there's a
large part of the public that that
doesn't have confidence and so how would
you address address that from
a you know what would you say to that
and how do how do you gain that
confidence that what we're doing in fact
will protect the public from any
potential hazards yeah I I think you
know from a permanent standpoint there's
a public process that you know
applications that get submitted get
notified they're out for public comment
they're made available in a public
location at City Hall at a local library
uh notifications are made to all the
butters
uh it's published in a local and a
Statewide permit uh public hearings are
held at the local level uh and at the
state level for any projects so there's
you know there's opportunities for folks
to weigh in address concerns that they
have through both of those processes so
um you know I I I know there's concern
on some facilities uh in the state but
you know that's you know we're we're
seeing the impact on our our operations
and trying to protect what we're doing
um but I understand there's concerns
with other things that are going on
Statewide so okay are there any
questions any other questions no I have
I have a question for the Department
okay thank you sir I appreciate you
coming up and taking the time today very
helpful thank you and Mr whms you got we
got about two minutes for one
question for one question well until we
run out of time and then we will have
another
session I don't know I just have to go
back to Optics the Optics of this whole
thing is is is um is quite upsetting
like I'm kind of stunned we basically
have just had all this testimony of yes
of the only people that you've met with
pretty much since October or heard from
and then the council are all the
industry they're and then we have no
disrespect but we have an industry
person
you know from Waste Management to come
speak why aren't we having a
hydrogeologist come talk to us I mean
the rules have become weaker and
weaker and and that's that's that's a
good thing I protective if we're going
to be protective it makes sense you made
a statement about Massachusetts they
have like a full moratorium we're taking
an out of state trash pretend to the
question please so how is it that we're
saying that we're doing good things and
all of that you make examples of U
Massachusetts and stuff and we're taking
an out of state trash from them so our
rules that are weaker are going to take
in more trash from other states that
have stricter
things don't you think that that's
that's what's happening aren't we going
to just take in more trash from other
people because our we're talking about
the rules for site locations that's the
that's what this subcommittee is about
that's so the questioning should be
along the lines of the rules for site
location
please right now our rules are hundreds
of times weaker and they've been made
that
progressively so in us saying not
looking at other states well aren't we
going to have to look at other states if
our aate trash is almost at 50% at this
point why aren't we looking at that if
we're making our rules weaker then we're
Hampshire I'm not sure what the question
question representative
Murray uh thank you um director can you
speak to the waste disposal hierarchy
and whether or not that is something
that we we have looked at that topic uh
in committees throughout this
environment and agriculture swag has
looked at those Solid Waste working
group as well do does the data that
comes from how
we
uh at what rate we are landfilling
versus other methods affect how you look
at the
rules I think it's fair well I will say
that you know one of the things that I
think has been a source of frustration
for the public and for the legislature
is that um we continue you know our if
you look at the port P folio of uh
facilities that accept Solid Waste in
New Hampshire the line share of the
waste um gets landfilled and of course
it's been pointed out many times that
landfilling is on the bottom of the
hierarchy we have U you know worked as
best we could to try to encourage other
types of facilities we don't propose
facilities we don't propose to construct
and operate facilities we receive permit
applications from those who wish to do
and we are Duty bound to process those
permit applications I am happy to report
that through um some legislative action
within the last couple of years we've
made some good progress on looking at
Food waste and organic waste which
comprises a very significant portion of
mssw that goes into landfills and um we
actually uh just within the last few
weeks received an application for an
Organics waste facility um not a
landfill um in the seast region so
that's a positive um a very positive
development something we've not seen yet
so uh we are making uh incremental
progress in that regard and we hope to
make certainly a lot more as as this
committee knows we've uh uh implemented
uh developed and published and are
implementing a 10year solid waste
management plan um that has this as many
of its goals to expand on that you and
to improve our position in the hierarchy
if you will and I think we're going to
make great progress there but we we
still have an A we clearly have a lot of
work to do thank you very okay thank you
so much for your testimony this morning
I appreciate you coming by you're
welcome um I we we'll take a look but we
might want to have another session
sooner rather than later if you're okay
with that and uh at at theit's pleasure
thank you sir I appreciate
that um so the subcommittee I just have
one question represent
Penza so your comment regarding the
waste management Council I think it it
has a lot of Merit and what I'd like to
do is send a note from the subcommittee
as a highlighted weakness to the
executive Council and and just send it
straight to them and say Hey listen
we're really not happy with this because
we're only getting one side of the would
you help me craft
that and because that I think that's the
way to you're exactly right on the issue
but I think the best way to handle that
is through the executive Council who's
the one that's supposed to fill those
slots so if you help me out with that
then I think that would be helpful thank
you any uh further questions great thank
target
okay uh we want to get underway here
late
right all
right do we know do we know who's
who's gonna be out today Lisa smart
out okay know out because her son her
daughter is in the
hospital who Kelly Kelly oh Kelly she's
gone she was here I thought her daughter
was in a hospital she was I don't know
her things are still there though stop
right so but she'll be leaving shortly
she has to leave by back sorry no
worries okay um so everybody please take
their seats and um representative Murray
allegiance to the flag of the United
States of America and to the Republic
for which it stands one nation under God
indivisible with liberty and justice for
all
okay good morning everybody and welcome
to environment and agriculture uh 10
o'clock we were supposed to start with a
work session where the committee is
going to discuss three bills HB 1102
which we heard yesterday HB 1145 and hb1
1632 um I I actually prefer to start
with um HB
1145 which is uh one of the landfill
bills um we didn't really have much time
to talk about that particular bill it's
um prohibiting the private ownership of
landfills and I kind of like to get uh
some thoughts from the committee
regarding that bill um I guess the
premise of the bill was so that we could
limit the amount of out ofate trash
coming into the state um and I don't
know does anybody have any um initial
thoughts on that particular
bill um yes repr Bixby um well not
surprisingly I support the bill
yeah um and uh so
uh one of the key things about uh one of
the key differences between um a
landfill being privately owned versus
publicly owned is that if it is publicly
owned
then the uh the public body whether it's
the state or the county or municipality
or a um or solid waste District uh would
have the ability to uh make the
essentially uh determine the rules for
what can and can't go into the landfill
and where that comes from so
um one of the issues with the um
with private landfills is that uh
because of the interstate commerce
clause there are uh real limits in terms
of what a what restrictions can be put
on on the type of waste and on the uh
the source of waste that can be that can
go into it uh so uh any um any rule that
uh for for public for privately owned
landfill any rule that the state uh puts
on the landfill needs to be applied
equally to both instate and outof state
waste and which means that uh there is
uh very limited very limited capacity to
uh to block out ofate waste uh and uh we
heard uh relative to the other bill that
we um that we heard along with this
that there may be uh some capacity to
say block as much waste in as an equal
percentage of the waste coming into the
state as we sent out of the state but
that would still mean that we we would
be forced to take at least uh as much as
perhaps 15% of out ofate waste we
wouldn't be able to uh restrict it
further than that the other thing is we
would not be able to make differential
fees between in instate and out ofate
waste uh we would not be able to uh
block specific items coming from out of
state unless we also block those from
instate so um and so there there are uh
all sorts of uh restrictions in terms of
what we C the the degree to which we can
control the waste going into landfills
if it's coming from if we if we're
talking about a private landfill uh if
we have a public landfill then we have
the capacity to make the laws and rules
that govern everything that goes into
that landfill and that uh given that uh
our
um our envir our natural environment is
one of our most important resources in
this state it drives tourism it drives
uh our capacity to provide safe drinking
water safe air Etc to the uh the people
in our in the State uh being able to put
in place rules that are sufficiently
protective is important for um for our
uh longterm long-term sustainability as
as a state both economically and um and
uh environmentally and in terms of
health so I think that putting making it
so that any future landfill would be
publicly owned is a um is an important
step to take the other thing that we
need to consider is that we aren't going
to be having very many new landfills we
already have capacity through uh
3035 and that doesn't include the likely
expansions that can that can happen at
the existing landfills um
so uh so the uh so I think that um the
idea that this is somehow going to um
restrict all sorts of commercial
possibilities is um not really a major
factor so my my question though is
there's nothing in State Statute now
that prohibits the state from opening a
landfill that's correct the state could
open a land fill uh but uh the
um but that also doesn't create that
also um doesn't prevent new public land
new private landfills from being
proposed and permitted and uh the I so
uh in order to
um in order so uh if we do not want to
have a situation where we have another
uh public privately owned landfill in
the state then uh we need then we need
to have a Prohibition on on new
privately owned
landfills uh and uh so that
um so that yes it is possible for a
municipality or or the state or a county
to um to come up with its own propos
proposal for landfill and it would have
to meet all of the necessary permitting
requirements that uh Dees now has but uh
the but I think that um having those
things
under uh state or County or Municipal
control gives the gives us the capacity
to control what's coming in from out of
state in a way that we never would have
with a private land F Well no I I
understand the premise of the differ
between you know how we can control a
publicly owned landfill as opposed to a
privately owned landfill in terms of the
Commerce Clause and what we can accept
as from out of state trash and what we
can charge for it and all of that but my
I I still contend that I mean if the
state believes that it's
um sort of a a priority to eliminate uh
as much out of state
trash then I would think that you know
they would have the impetus to want
to establish a public
landfill I could do
that I could do
that
um but my point is that I mean there's
nothing that prohibits the state from
from going ahead and doing this as
opposed to Banning private
ownership uh of a landfill I mean we
presum presumably what you want to do is
is compel the state to then establish
future landfills only if there is a
capacity need that is not being filled
and right and it is also possible that
there may be other municipalities or
counties that would uh feel that it
would be to their advantage to uh to
establish their own landfill uh and we
have several
successful uh municipally owned
landfills I four out of the six of the
operating landfills right now are
municipally owned and they are doing a
very good job uh so um are they do you
know if they're limiting how much out of
state trash they're taking
in yes n yeah um so in nashaa does I
and put your mic uh they police it um
especially on Saturdays so that people
can't come from other communities and
dump their trash in
nashwa so um representative Howard um
two points um I think that uh that if we
were to have only state run we would
eliminate the comp competition from um
which you know I know is a little bit
anema to uh to um one side of the aisle
here but um I also think that the
business proposition that one of the the
naysayers against this was the business
um community and um I I still don't I
would still believe that not all
business opportunities are equal and and
we would be in better hands um if the
state was running it especially if it if
it overrides the Commerce um
laws representative H Haskins thank you
madam chair there's a reason why we
haven't done this why the state hasn't
come up with it this is a billion dollar
industry they are not interested in
local control it you know it is very
hard to compete in the laws and rules as
are currently constructed and I agree
with everything that um rep Bixby said
and I can't improve on it I think local
control is very important and we don't
have it
now okay represent Duty uh thank you um
I I wish I could um cite the article um
verbatim but I can't but I was reading
an article uh recently and the way it we
stacked up in the negative um regarding
landfilling and recycling we were number
11 in the negative Connecticut
Massachusetts Vermont and Maine and
possibly even Rhode Island were all in
the positive they were like number 46 47
48 and 49 in the positive in terms of uh
limiting e either limiting the amount of
landfilling that they're doing or
improving the amount of recycling
they're doing okay that's number one
secondly um I went to a conference on
Monday there were people there from all
across the country and when they found
out that I was from New Hampshire what
do you think the first thing they said
we love going to New Hampshire I've been
to New Hampshire it's a beautiful state
it's a Serene State we really love your
state and my response was well some of
us are trying to keep it that way okay
so I mean I would really be very uh Pro
this bill as one step and the other
thing is by maintaining private
landfills we are inadvertently
encouraging in trash okay because we're
because there's money in it okay it's
easy there's money in it you know and we
are inadvertently
encouraging uh people not to take the
time to recycle reuse or
refill so are you saying then that if
the state owned the landfill that the
state wouldn't be making that money no
what I'm saying is is that if there's
money to be made then we are
inadvertently incentivizing Private
Industry okay to open landfills um and
sell the land I mean and you know people
with a lot of land that want to get rid
of it you know are incentivized then to
sell it to these companies as long as
they pass the de regulations nobody can
do anything about it and what we need to
be thinking about is just like
representative Bixby has said it should
should be need based just like they do
with hospitals okay a private company
can't come in and build a new hospital
just because they bought a piece of land
there has to be a needs assessment and
and our land is you know we're not
making any more of it it's very
important and right now the there's
nothing to prevent a company that thinks
they can make money to buy a piece of
property get it permitted and so we
could have a flood
of landfills which is exactly what we
don't
want um represent Bixby go back on this
i' like to point out one other aspect of
this bill is that if the uh if the
landfill were to be state-owned it would
have to be managed by a private company
which would then provide a business
opportunity uh and so that and and it
could provide it could be a fairly
lucrative Pro you know
uh business opportunity for the for a
company that wanted to do the U
construction and management of a
landfill uh and uh they would still have
to meet all of the regulations that we
have for how landfills are constructed
and run but uh but it means that uh that
that the operation of the landfill is
really where the money is in the in the
business is not uh not so much that you
necessarily own the land but Phill but
you are getting the constant in Revenue
stream from the
operation um representative
Penza yeah I I agree with what
representative Bixby said in in several
statements that representative um Duty
said so this is we're talking about
something that possibly will have one of
one in the next hundred years and so
it's a it's a public private partnership
and in a sense it's like think of it
like a public utility we're not talking
about stifling a business or something
like that and that's creating widgets
we're talking about trash and um which
has impacts on everything from the
environment and all that kind of stuff
the skin in the game is that the state
owns the property but everything else
99% of everything else is run on that
from the experts that do it you know
like a waste management or something
that that runs it that has to fall
through all of the same criteria I
just representative Roch Rochester
doesn't do it that way but um actually
in in Maine I believe that the the
landfill that um that cassella operates
is that they are a public private
partnership like that so meaning Maine
owns the the the the land and then of
course cassella operates it so just
another example representative
Katon I
mean I guess first of all I'm not the
public private partnership makes sense
to me even though I'm not into the state
owning and
operating you know that that's just not
what I believe should be
happening but the one question I've got
and I get push back against
representative Bixby a little bit that I
don't understand is that yeah they build
it they operate it and today they build
it and they operate they make a profit
but if you take away out of state trash
what does that do to the profit margin
and is it still profitable because as I
understand it the amount of trash we
bring in 48% I think is what we heard a
couple weeks ago is a substantial amount
of the money that they make and so then
is it is it still profitable I don't
know the answer to
that represent VI Fe so um given the
volume of trash that we produce in New
Hampshire uh the so there's actually two
levels to this one is that if there's
not a need for it then there there would
be no incentive for the state to set up
a landfill if there's a need for it then
that the fact that there's a need for it
means that there is going to be enough
trash to provide a revenue stream uh the
other aspect of this is that uh if you
if we look at Waste Management in
Rochester
uh they they do landfilling but they
also have a very extensive recycling
operation as well and a so uh one of the
things that some that a if if we did
have a uh state-owned landfill that was
operated by a private company that
private company could establish multiple
revenue streams by doing things with the
trash that was not landfilling it it and
uh so uh having having a sort of a comp
having a a public landfill that was part
of a comprehensive waste management
system uh would be uh would be a real
benefit for the
state representative
K thank you madam
chair I understand the reasoning behind
the
bill but we can't compare
Public Utilities with this because
state-owned I like the idea of A needs
assessment uh regarding landfills I
think uh we should look at the need of
the
state
however I re am really concerned about
the state owning the landfill I
understand the interstate commerce
laws but but if we are going to get
better at recycling and everything
else then and we want to encourage
that and as representative Bix me
mentioned waste management is you know
really getting into the recycling aspect
of
things then that would actually limit
the amount of waste going into a
landfill and we also have to remember
that we send our hazardous waste out of
state
what if all of a sudden where we send
our hazardous waste decides to do a
state-owned landfill and no longer take
waste and do exactly what we're trying
to do what are we going to do with our
hazardous waste
then I think we need to be very
this because
because it's it's a really important
topic and we need to be cognizant of our
tourism but having the state own it
isn't going to get rid of landfills
we're still going to have a landfill
whether it's privately owned or publicly
owned we still need trash are going to
have
crash if they're going to do recycling
they're going to need to have more
profitable so if we want to look at
something based on needs assessment I
think that's a great
cautious represent Howard thank you
madam chair so um I guess that my first
question is sort of answered
I think it's still possible to make a
profit managing a a landfill and so we
we would be able to invite people to to
partake in that I really believe that
the um that the management should be
close to the source of the regulation or
the or the ownership should be close to
the regul the source of the regulation
so this would be the advantage of having
the state own it when we all know that
that they have not been able to stop the
leech it from any of the landfills that
we that have been in New Hampshire and
um so many brownfields get deserted by
the owner ERS just they just walk away
from them I think that if the state owns
it it would we would have a better
chance of of better management of the
leech a and also better cleanup
afterwards represent dsy thank you madam
chair I just want to make two points
first of all our responsibility is to
the people of New Hampshire uh we do not
have a responsibility to make sure that
Private Industry makes a profit that's
their job okay and if they can't make a
profit then they're going to do
something else and and then we do
something else so that's the chess game
of life that's what you do the second
thing is is that by having it state
owned we control capacity and I think
that that's what I was trying to say
before and that is what is critical um
because if you again if you allow it to
priv Private Industry and there's a
profit to be made then there can be
overc capacity and we have you know I
mean just look at the retail space
I mean we are so wasteful in this
country in that we get on a fad
everybody builds buildings uh you know
and then all of a sudden there's nobody
there to occupy the buildings uh so now
there's retail space that's empty we
chewed up land we have um you know uh
more impervious surfaces that we have to
deal with you have the same thing in
Office Buildings right now do we really
want that in
landfills representative DAV
this thank you madam chair my my
question is with a landfill that's state
owned and privately run where would
liability lie in case of an incident
would the state be on the hook for like
I not that I'm in agreement with this
but I I've heard it said a lot of times
not if it leaks but when it leaks will
the state be responsible for that of of
course it
would yeah represent Bixby so um
so one of the things that uh is not in
this bill because um there is not an
actual plan for a state land state-owned
landfill right now is uh the details of
how the state would have to
um how how the state would do the
acquisition of the land or the assign or
the assessment assignment of the land
and how the St State most importantly
how the state would set up the contract
with the management the waste
corporation that was hired to manage it
there would be an RFP and there would be
a contract with that management
organization and the liability would be
something that would be spelled out in
that
contract okay representative kto thank
you madam
chair there is nothing right now
prohibiting municipalities or
regions from doing a PP part
parnership as we said four out of the
six
landfills are publicly
owned and maybe if there was another
landfill it could try the pp partnership
thing with the municipality not
necessarily the state or the region
where they want to put it there's
nothing prohibiting that from happening
right now municipalities and regions
have the ability to do this why are we
putting it in statute because if you if
your region wants to have a landfill so
that they can limit what comes in for
it um I want to also uh dovetail and I
mean we can talk about hb1
1632 as in this entire discussion as
well and that bill just merely um it
doesn't ban private ownership of
landfills but it allows um privately
owned landfills to put a 15% cap on out
ofate
trash and um I mean for me I think that
that's a more
reasonable um compromise on this
because you're still uh allowing the
ability of uh limiting the amount of out
ofate trash within the confines of the
Commerce Clause and then you know you're
not um you're not Banning private
private ownership um so what what are
your thoughts on that representative H
Haskins thank you madam chair I just
wanted to go back for a moment um
again the RFP suggests that if there's a
profit to be made the company can make
you know the offer and this is a billion
doll industry so we really don't have to
worry in my view about their ability to
make a profit state-owned or otherwise
um so secondly again local control very
important to a lot of people in the
legislature and this would give us um
more of that and as rep Davis said
um leni's leak and we just heard
testimony in the subcommittee about
double line ERS and all the length at
which companies go to ensure that it
doesn't happen but it does and so I
think having the state uh owning the
land gives us agency that we lack right
now and I say again there's a reason why
they haven't done it why the state
hasn't done it it is very hard to
compete with a billion dollar industry
and all the lobbyists that they have so
um I'm very supportive of this bill and
when it comes to the next one um I I
don't want New Hampshire to be known for
trash we've got to look forward in this
topic we're not you know we have
capacity right now and don't need more
until 34 or 35 so I want us to look down
the road um at what we can do to enhance
the the methodology for recycling and
for food waste and all the rest of it
and
not open ourselves up to um an industry
that wants to make a lot of money and
take our natural
resources representative ktoa and then
thank you madam chair um just a question
on something that you said um regarding
HB
1632 um you said that it would allow
privately owned landfills to put a cap
on but doesn't the bill state that they
might that the cap would be
15% um it's not that they could do that
it's that they must do
that um so just wanted to clarify
that represent Penza my gosh I've got a
bunch of questions now um
so first I wanted to say this goes back
on a statement I'm not sure who made it
but you know we talk about we and all
that kind of stuff in regards with with
the private companies but these private
companies one of course is in Vermont
and the other one is in is in Texas I
mean we're not talking about New
Hampshire based businesses you know that
are operating in this private private
landfill so I want that to be clear like
we're you know we're not necessarily
enriching um you know New Hampshire
business but here nor there and then the
other piece in regards with
1632 um thank you for clarifying so if
we're going to put that you know that
hard stop on it then you know maybe you
know maybe 11:40 five isn't necessary
I'm not sure but
um I I still think if you look at where
we're at right now the the current
situation that we're at
there the state is already on the hook
for for every problem that happens so
there are no I put a bill in and it's
not going to go through I'll try it
again but shity bonds if if you're going
to come into the if you're going to come
into the state and you're going to have
landfill or something a great example
let's just talk about you know the
elephant in the room of St gobain they
are now out they're cut and run and most
of these companies as you know they
claim bankruptcy they found a new LLC
and then we're on the hook for it I I'm
working on a report right now that shows
this of New Hampshire and the super fund
sites so I mean we have to look at that
we're all paying for that whether it's
federal or not that's all our money so
we really have to start look shity bonds
are a a constant thing if you're going
to come here and we know that all
landfills leak at some point then um it
having that insurance policy whether
it's state whether it's private whatever
to protect us in the fer to protect the
taxpayers that's what we should be doing
most almost all other states have that
if you're going to be doing something
that's potentially going to be hazardous
in the future that could wipe out
drinking water for an entire region I
mean yeah that's it's big deal so just
my two
cents representative Bixby yeah so um I
don't I don't see uh the 1145 and and
1632 as being an either War I think that
um I I think it's a both end and uh so
in terms of um in terms of 1632 uh I
think that it does make sense to uh put
a 15% cap on the on outof state waste um
and I think that uh one of but one of
the things that um I'm a little bit
worried about with this bill is you know
what happen how will it Faire in court
um I think that uh we in terms of um in
terms of the the solidness of the legal
aspect of it I think that um 1145 is is
a bit stronger but in terms of uh the
you know how quickly it could be uh
effective I think that that uh that um
1632 might be uh more effective in the
short run representative Davis thank you
madam chair if the intent of of House
Bill
1145 is to limit out
ofate uh trash coming here what why
wouldn't that take the place of uh 1632
I mean we're looking to limit the amount
of trash that would do it so why why
would we need
to represent kto thank you madam chair
um we just put a moratorium on landfills
we just passed a bill that no landfill
could be cited until
well it passed the house but this body
passed this committee passed that and it
house it hasn't been on consent yet I
don't think oh it has not passed the
house yet okay I apologize but I believe
that it's on it's on the consent it's on
the consent calendar and I do believe
that it will be the will of the body to
put a moratorium on
landfills I
think um I just want everyone to
there let me just double
consent yes it is it is on the consent
calendar for
tomorrow it off just going to throw that
out so
no representative Howard and then H
Haskins thank you mam ch um I I just
really want to emphasize what I said and
what representative Penza also
vehemently said Private Industry walks
away from brownfields um so I think that
if we're if we are going to have
landfills in the future we need to have
it the the owners of the landfills be
the ultimate responsibility
responsible entity I think that we you
know they it's just too risky to put
that much poison into the ground and not
and have and leave it up to the industry
to clean up representative H Haskins
thank you madam chair um hopefully the
moratorium is good but that's 28 that's
not 34 and it's not 54 if Waste
Management indeed extends the life of
one that they have in the state which
there's every reason to believe they
will so again we don't have a capacity
issue right now but we do have an issue
of protecting our natural resources and
our environment and anything we can do
that favors that I think we should do
represent kraton yeah I just wanted to
to clarify the profitability
statement it's not about the company
making money it's it's about can the
make money can the company make money
and if you you if you set it up and the
company can't make money on it then they
won't come and now you have well okay
that's great representative Duty they
don't come so now what do we do with all
our stuff and you know and so now you
got more to representative Howard now
you got more brand Fields because they
left represent Dy thank you with all due
respect representative kraton okay
businesses are in business to make money
if they can't make money they'll do
something else if we we need those
businesses to be here then we will do
something else that's part of the
negotiation that's part of the contract
that's part of Coming to Terms okay um
but the fact of the matter is and I
don't know if any of you have been
following the steart hospital A Private
Hospital uh in in Boston that has
basically gone bankrupt although the CEO
has a $40 million yacht and I believe
another one that he's building that
might be $20 million at the same time
they uh people are they have a lack of
supplies because they haven't been
paying their bills okay and the and the
state of Massachusetts or whoever the US
government is going to be stuck with
that a private hospital so the same
thing can become can happen here with
landfills and I don't see a problem with
having State ownership you know a
partnership it's going to be run by a
private company and you come to an
agreement I mean that's basically it
they need us for their business we need
them you know to to handle the issue
that we have that's how you do it okay
um representative
Katon
okay my point is representative Duty
representative
Duty representative
Duty thank you my my point is why would
we do
something that would create that
situation as opposed to working our way
through it and not creating that
situation and that that's my concern I
don't know the answer but I don't want
to create something that's a problem
that doesn't have to be created just
point of order but repes okay
representative Katon it's not it it it's
not a foregone conclusion hold on one
second go ahead we just remember that
the questions get directed through the
chair and that we're not directly
debating one another thank you you
appreciate that okay continue your
answer and then we'll go on to
representative
Bixby Madam
chair with 35 years experience in
business having worked with many
governments around the
world uh having to be a part of
negotiating
contracts uh for um very important
things like issuing government
passports I recognize that that is part
of the business process okay you issue
for example what we would probably do is
issue a an
RFP for uh people to apply uh to um uh
work the landfill uh to operate the
landfill and again I've said this before
if nobody responds this then we're being
unreasonable so then we change the RFP
you know we work with industry you you
work with them you say what's the
problem here how can we come to terms
well if you change this then we might be
willing to bid on the project okay so we
change that they bid on the project and
it really is a public private
partnership so it it doesn't have to be
um contentious we just come to an
agreement because we we have a problem
to solve and Industry wants to make a
profit that and that's fine so um you
know that's works so I think that um
it's pretty clear that uh there are some
people who are in FA in favor of um 1145
and there are some who were opposed and
however much we talk in the next 15
minutes or the next hour or the next you
know however long that's probably not
going to change so uh I suggest that we
move on to the other business we have uh
my so I am wondering if there is anyone
who objects to uh the to uh
1632 and if there are objections then
bring those up otherwise I think and my
sense is that we may be in pretty well
in agreement on that if there's no
objections to 1632 I suggest we move on
to the other large animal in the room I
know
metaphorically speaking yes um uh yeah
um for me I mean I I I would be uh in
favor of uh HB 1632 I think a 15% cap on
out of state trash is is very reasonable
um representative Davis yes thank you
madam chair I I'm in agreement with 1632
and I think that would take care of the
problem for 1145 we're trying to limit
out of state
trash okay well I think um I think we'
pretty much um exhausted that and I know
that we have some differences of
philosophy in terms of private ownership
versus uh State ownership or um
Municipal ownership public ownership
whatever you want to call it so with
that I think um I'm going to move on
from from those two landfill bills and
we can then begin discussion on uh what
we heard yesterday for HB
1102 which is um relative to the
definition of animal cruelty uh would
somebody like to uh make some comment on
testimony that they heard
yesterday represent
Penza um for people that weren't able to
hear the um the entire hearing because
it was long that were absent I think
probably uh the best testimony came at
the end and um from the woman that
worked for the SPCA I think it was she
was a veterinarian
and um and I I really I appreciated
everything that she said it was very
thoughtful and gave just you know kind
of all ends of the spectrum and in in
realizing that um legislatively she
doesn't see how this could be solved um
but that it really needed to be um the
stakeholders whether it be the you know
in the situation whether it with the
Breeders and veterinarians and um and
whatnot that came together and that
really that that worked out this issue
in regards with you know the um the
rating system and and all of that kind
of
stuff from from what I heard too
um I think that the the the breeders in
New Hampshire do a very good job um
of breeding and raising animals in a
very ethical and good way I think they
are doing a great
job um and also to um the testimony
yesterday with regard to complaints to
the AG's office um we haven't really
heard of any issues with um you know
animals being sold that are uh having
problems their owners are spending
thousands and thousands of dollars for
surgeries and are claiming um you know
some kind of problem consumer problem
with the AG's office it's just doesn't
seem to be happening and as we talked to
several breeders who um who are not
aware in their
Community um of any major issues or
higher percentages of animals that are
having
issues um
and I think what we also heard was that
you know Brey saili in and of itself is
not an issue is not a problem it's it's
a description of an animal skull um and
it's it's not uh something that equates
to illness or sickness there are brais
spelic uh dogs pigs cats whatever that
are perfectly healthy and there are no
problems um I think
they you know
the the whole issue of intentionally
breeding sick animals I don't know that
our breeders would intentionally do that
because look at they're trying to sell
healthy animals so um so I I I just I
see a lot of problems with this bill
representative coma thank you madam
chair um we heard a lot of testimony
yesterday
but represent patens was right some
really um the testimony at the end of
the day was very thoughtful um there
were a couple people that really stood
out uh the one that uh had 22
years and and uh and as an animal
consultant has worked in animal cruelty
SPCA and the one thing
that's stuck out to me and I can attach
to it personally that I understand this
is one
Bry braie Breaky
suff okay um is a
description and
breeders do their best in the state of
New Hampshire we have very good animal
laws on our
books we require Health certificates we
have
um we animal cruelty laws that prevent
this type of issue uh from people from
breeding like this it's probably why we
don't hear a lot about it in New
Hampshire but the other thing that
really stuck out stuck out with me is
because I have owned three of the
breeds that are listed as break eelic a
Rottweiler
a
sharp and a
boxer all those dogs were healthy there
was never any issues with
them as someone who
crosses I can tell you that I have never
had any issues with my girls I no longer
breed so um have puppies but my girls
and my sire never had any health issues
everything was selling over 30
puppies I had ran into one person that
got one of my puppies and it has all
allergies and when I ask these folks do
you think it could be from environmental
issues based on
the owner of the dog they said yes we
have to be cognizant that when people
purchase a puppy or a dog sometimes they
could be perfectly healthy but
environmental issues like feeding it too
much making it overweight not giving it
an ex enough exercise putting it in a
home where there's smoke can all cause
issues that can lead to these what you
know these severe health issues
you can have the best intentions you can
have no issues with your your
animals and still have a
puppy that you get passes the health
certificate and you find out later on
and the only thing I could contribut it
to was the environmental issues and I
just want everyone to we heard that
testimony from both of those folks that
environmental issues are huge in causing
these problems
represent Bixby yeah so um I see looking
at the this bill I see two two sort of
um sections or or way or angles on it uh
one angle on it is what is the
underlying problem and the other angle
is what is the suggested remedy and I
think that there uh there we did did
have evidence that there is a problem
among some dogs that uh have a brachos
phalic uh um characteristic that uh
there are health issues that can be uh
either um cre there can be a a
propensity towards it for the in in some
dogs that have those characteristics but
it is hardly a guarantee uh and that uh
Al and so um maybe there's a higher
probability of these problems but it's
not a guarantee uh we can't necessarily
eliminate that uh by uh or breeders
cannot necessarily completely eliminate
those problems by their breeding choices
although they may be able to make some
real progress it sounds like the uh AKC
certified breed ERS do in fact work
towards uh making sure that uh they are
breeding towards a healthy
standard
uh however uh so so yes there is a
problem out there exactly how it whether
um exactly how much of a problem it's a
little bit hard for us to gauge we heard
a fair amount of conflicting testimony
in terms of the solution this is where
the this is what really kills the bill
for me uh the solution is to put it into
the animal cruelty statutes we had a
description of how those how an animal
cruelty investigation is carried out and
given the way that it's carried out the
language of the bill would make it
impossible to actually execute a
successful uh animal cruelty
investigation uh
with with the language that was uh
laying out what was considered cruel uh
so uh the fact that the the remedy is
impossible and the uh and the problem is
uh not entirely clearly
defined uh and that the language in the
bill that was trying to define the
problem doesn't Define it does not
define the problem very clearly I think
that pretty much tells me that this is a
bill that is
sufficiently far from prime time that uh
it it doesn't even deserve an interim
study represent Howard um I just to
piggy back on um uh on representative
bixby's um description of the language I
think that the language in the bill
actually negates any possibility of it
passing first of all um the reference to
birth deformity we learned
yesterday whether you whether you
whether they thought that the the skull
shape c cused the problem or not they
all said that it was not a deformity so
there's that and I also think that the
inclusion of intentional breeding is
hard to prove and um and probably not
helpful to the language to the bill of
the
bill representative Murray thank you
madam chair um one of the other things
that I thought um was worth mentioning
and I I agree with representative
penza's Point um with the last person
who testified there was conversation
about sort of
uh national language around this as well
and I thought that sort of that was a
very powerful statement as to the
direction of of um what breed standards
were're looking at or those types of
things and then there was also testimony
around Boaz Boaz testing metrics to uh
have puppies um tested for pre-existing
health conditions so for everything
representative Bixby said I agree
wholeheartedly with some of the the
flaws around that and so um that's
really where I am at on it as well
represent
Kenny um yes thank you for um taking my
question um statement I have worked in
the veterinary field since I was 16 and
the majority of my career has been in
veterinary hospitals I actually worked
with the last speaker um so um I really
felt that the end of the day really
present
more of what was really happening and um
one of the Breeders I remembered from
when I was at the um animal hospital
I've worked with many breeders over the
years they are truly devoted to their
animals and doing the best whether it's
cats or dogs so I really feel that this
bill is really we can't legislate this I
really feel like it's not something I
think it's something that needs to be
um through the um
AKC and breeders and veterinarians to
really solve this and that they really
need to do the work and I think that the
breeders in New Hampshire um are
extremely
um conscientious so I really feel that
this is something that uh we really need
to itl thank you
representative
kraton thank you madam chair yeah I'd
also like to go back to Dr Parker or Dr
Proctor rather when she said that and as
I reread the bill I think she's right
the impact on the animal shelters so you
know you're going to get these animals
regardless of how they're bred or how
where they came up from and the animal
shelters then can't sell them based on
this law I think that's a second or
third order effect that we probably
wouldn't
want represent H Haskins thank you madam
chair I just want to go on record to say
that I learned a lot
yesterday and I'm we always do I'm very
grateful to the sponsor for putting the
bill forward because there was so much I
didn't know about my own
granddogs and I'm going to take that
information back to my children because
I'm thinking that they don't know some
of the things that I learned yesterday
one of whom spent thousands of dollarss
to have um a
terrier uh hospitalized because
apparently
the spaying did the surgery did not go
well so they went through a very
reputable breeder but things happen and
go wrong but anyway um hats off to the
sponsor for allowing us to hear the
information that was um very informative
and useful well I have to say too you
know I guess you most of us are dog
owners or know people have dogs or
whatever and and I I can't seem to get
away from the fact that when when you
adopt a
pup there's always going to be something
that happens I mean we've got a um a um
dog a black lab
Ridgeback and um one of the one of the
things of that breed is because of the
ridgeback sometimes there's a hair on
the back that grows into the spine and
they end up getting an abscess and it's
it's um it's a thing it cost us several
thousands of dollars for surgery to have
that taken care of um and have that hair
extracted and removed and all the
abscess and everything cleared out so I
mean you just never know with some of
these breeds what kinds of things are
going to happen and I I don't you know I
don't know if that would the breeder
would have come under this kind of um of
legislation is that considered a birth
deformity is that something a ridgeback
is that something that would fall under
this and then so what happens to that
breed you're no no longer able to breed
those animals um so I I I just there's a
lot that's packed into this language
here that um I I just I can't agree with
and um and I get it you know there's
there's some people out there that may
be wanting to go to extremes with
certain uh characteristics of animals
but I mean how do you prove intent how
do you prove a lot of this is as what uh
representative Bixby had pointed out in
any case are there any other comments
regarding this bill I think that uh we
can probably move
on yep oh represent fenza just wanted to
um do the same thing that representative
has Haskins said in hats off to um to to
bringing this forward I mean there was I
don't know I'm new here but this was the
bit busiest that we've ever been in here
and um and it was uh it was it was
exciting and um I know that there was
you know a little bit of stuff but for
the most part I think that
[Music]
um you know sometimes healing from the
woman that spoke which was uh that was
really hard to hear and uh and bringing
this forward I think is um is huge and
maybe that means that these parties that
can fix this outside of legislatively
can really um to work towards um making
something happen but um facilitating
this I think was great and and thank you
for
that represent Bixby yeah I'd also like
to thank the chair for her uh carefully
setting the tone at the beginning of the
hearing to uh alleviate as much as
possible of the tension that tends to
come up in these hearings because I have
seen some animal hearings in my past
that have been extremely fraught and I
thought that on the whole the entire
tone throughout the four hours plus of
testimony was quite civil thank you I
appreciate that thank
you takes a committee I'll tell you you
guys did a great job too and hanging in
there for for um that length of time um
in any case I'd like to close out our
work
session and uh I guess it's time for us
to uh move along to a
today um let's see HB
gavel
okay I'm going to open up um the hearing
on hb1 1463 establishing a committee to
study the effects of laws relative to
the production of beef pork and poultry
and our um sponsor of the bill uh
representative ktoa take it away thank
you madam chair for the record uh
representative coma representing map 7
Alton um this bill came about due to a
study committee that represented Bixby
and I were on uh when we heard
uh
testimony from people in the
agricultural industry um
that were receiving different
information regarding laws
um and it was conflict
conflicting and what we discovered is or
what I discovered was that if
you use one law at the federal level you
can't use a state law if you use state
law you can't use another state law
there's very conflicting information out
there and it's very
confusing and when we spoke to these
Farmers uh in the meat industry
they thought it would be a great idea to
have all the information in one spot and
POS and have um it on the State website
and possibly a brochure or some type of
report so there's just one place you can
go to uh to know what to do instead of
searching um in
agriculture um I I used the old adage I
thought I was pretty up to date on
things until until I get involved in uh
Agriculture and then I've realized I
knew nothing um because of so many laws
that are on the books that you have to
deal with um people do not realize it
and so I think just to start and get
this
portion in one area will be extremely
helpful to the farmers in our state and
questions Okay so um so this sets up a
study
committee yes and ostensively
um so the the study committee is
supposed to be presenting the report
November 1st so we would have to have
that done this year correct correct okay
and
um judging from
the the subject
matter do you have a sense of how many
meet
um it's going to take work I can tell
you that um we're going to need to uh
utilize uh the
researcher we're going to um really need
guidance from the Department of
Agriculture from the
USDA and you know I know that it only
says here for beef pork and poultry
producers but I have people contacting
me can you please include this can you
please include that PE people want this
so I think that we can try but I think
that beef pork and poultry are what we
produce most of I know people want us to
include bison and elk and other uh meats
that we produce in the state in red tail
but I think it's extremely important
that this be a start I don't know if
we'll get to everything but I think we
need to start somewhere representative
Howard I just have a quick question
about the um the entity so it's it's its
own committee so I see down here under
number five the report go does not go
through this committee it goes directly
to the speaker is that is that routine
and
and um would we would the committee
contribute any this committee contribute
anything uh no that is routine that it
would go through the speaker um it would
be a separate committee unto this
committee representative Bixby so um
according to the bill the project of
this committee is going to be a report
uh and but uh it sounds like your
ultimate goal is to have a u public
education document that would come out
of it and how would that publication
document get
created well you are correct
representative Bixby it is my goal is
for a public education document I think
that the report through the work that
the committee does will we will be
discovering a lot of the stuff that's
going on and I think from that report a
public education document could be
formed and follow up follow up okay and
who would be responsible for
promulgating that public education
education document would that go would
that go through the department website
for in perhaps and if so would we need
to do anything other than just ask them
pretty please I would ask them pretty
please okay represent
muray thank you madam chair and uh thank
you to the sponsor for taking my
question I um a question that I do have
regarding the report um because this
committee does have oversight over a
fair amount of this are you open to the
possibility of in the inclusion um a
copy of the report being sent to house
environment and agriculture of course
you represent Bixby so um in the uh in
interest of legislative efficiency I
think that we might not need to have
that report officially sent to the
committee by having an amendment on the
bill right because I I think I'd like to
see I'd like to see us uh EXA this bill
in not too terribly long could could we
do that now uh well I think we we' have
to close the hearing and open an ex
session right uh if the if the prime
sponsor would be willing oh
absolutely um do we have a quorum for
that have AUM one two three four five
second I I think it's half I think it's
yeah
I
representative thank you madam chair I
believe we have additional members
coming this
afternoon can we exec it in the
afternoon I believe it's the same I um
what does the announcement say it's on
the same announcement does it say does
it say it can't be exact exact same day
probably on the calendar section where
listed so
back after all before the amendment but
after
there pursuant to house rule 44b
executive session on bills may be taken
up during the day in which they are
heard okay okay so yeah we could do it
this afterno we could do it this
afternoon then all right um I'm going to
and I am going to open up the hearing
for HP 1628 relative to the regulatory
Authority for apples coal grating
potatoes cider milk and lumber cider mil
cider milk
yes oh that sounds
[Laughter]
nasty do you have the amendment I don't
way
no
no okay um so representa
Bixby we have I just want to bring up
something on my computer so we'll take
your time chose I'm going to make some
reference to uh the two chapters of
Statute that this is affecting but I
didn't think that it was worth Point
printing out 20 Pages for everybody so
um okay and oh I need to grab
my
oh I'll I'll do a pink I'll put together
a pink card after I finish talking
okay all right okay so uh for the record
uh representative Peter Bixby from Dober
New Hampshire representing straford
County
13 um and um
uh uh HB
1628 uh is the result of a study
committee that uh we put together uh in
response to a bill we heard last year uh
that was just looking at making some
changes to the oversight of Apple uh um
the Apple inspection
and uh so uh we had a study committee
with um myself and representative kraton
representative Ankerberg and Senator
Pearl uh and we looked through all of
chapters uh 426 and
434 to figure out which elements of
those were still relevant and which were
uh were no longer needed in state law
and uh so I'm going to give you a uh
just a quick sense of uh what some of
the things in chapter
434 were that we uh discussed and uh and
what we decided to do with them so um
starts out with standard boxes uh so
standard boxes are no longer a thing
that has any bearing in the way that um
produce is handled in the state so uh we
don't need to have an exact definition
of a standard box con containing
21628 n cubic inches uh so um we chose
to uh delete that part of the law
um and then we get on to the laws having
to do with ice
dealers um and we don't have the ice
wagons coming by anymore so uh we
decided that was not relevant um and we
don't have to worry about any person
selling anite coal which might have
bones in it uh
and uh so that we decided to eliminate
um and uh then we get into uh questions
having to do with the grating of
potatoes that is entirely covered under
federal law right now uh and the
department does no inspection for that
so that uh is being removed from uh in
this bill
um and
uh then we get on
to uh the grading of apples and the
department still does pay attention to
Apple grading uh however there are a lot
of details in apple grading that are no
longer necessary uh and uh so in the
original uh bill that I that you have
you were you were handed out uh there is
uh still ex extensive information about
Apple grading uh in the amendment that I
put forward that is pretty much reduced
to one sentence that says that the um
the standards that that the state
standards will be equal to the federal
standards because when the state does
inspections of apples it is you it is
already using those Federal standards
and uh so um we are just that will just
catch us up with current practice uh
there is a whole section on Apple
marketing which is uh once again Falls
entirely under the purview of the USDA
at this point uh so anything having to
do with apple marketing is once again
something that we follow federal law on
um and uh that gets us down to
um the uh manufacturing sale of cider
and uh that we actually do have
inspection of still and uh but we have
once we get down to cider uh so Apple
once we get down to apple cider and
Timber uh everything else in 434 has
been eliminated so rather than keeping
434 on the books with a few orphans in
it we decided to move everything to
426 so um so every so in
426 uh in the in the bill in 426 we'll
we'll have the information on uh
matching USDA standards for apples we'll
have the existing language uh that we
have in the state for cider and we'll
have the existing language we have in
the state for Timber Harvest for Timber
grading uh so that is uh what happens
with
434 um and in
426 uh we went through and we found
fewer items that needed to be removed
but if on your um Bill sheet you go
to um let's see uh section three on page
which is on page three starting at line
32 um are you talking about the
Amendments on this is this is the
passation on the amendment on the
amendment okay thank you um and the am
the amendment replaces the bill okay um
I should have mentioned that so um we
went through and uh we determined that
the definition of organic is done is
done federally so that didn't need to
stay here uh the similarly the labeling
and advertising of organic um and we
removed two aspects of uh certif Organic
certification because there were things
that the department long no longer did
there remains in statute one section on
uh Organic certification which is for
the certification of crops and um that
needs to remain in place uh for now uh
so after we uh a after the organic bill
that I proposed and we heard on the
floor last week uh did not pass uh there
was new information that came to the
department that they were losing one of
their inspectors which would have
reduced them to two inspectors and uh
the the commissioner felt that uh if one
of the if one additional inspector were
to leave for some reason uh uh whether a
health reason or uh you know family
reasons or whatever uh that uh the
department would be in the in the
position of not being able to fil
fulfill National Organics program
requirements and that the department
would not be able to legally
certify um Carry Out certification
duties and
the so the commissioner felt that it was
a it was better to
uh to uh get people to move to
Alternative certifiers in the region uh
now before the growing season begins
rather than have the risk of people
being partway through the season and
having to and and having that suddenly
taken away uh so uh at this point the
department need needs the that
existing uh the existing Authority that
has to run the Organic certification
program until it completes winding down
the program uh but uh the um uh but that
so that is not something that this bill
is removing um and uh the bill also so
the uh regulatory Services promotional
products fund was a dedicated fund that
typically had under $1,000 in it and it
would be used to deposit the receipts
from selling uh uh Department of
Agriculture you uh Department of
Agriculture markets and Foods labels and
signs to Farmers uh for their promotions
and uh it would also pay for the
production of those and it was It was
decided uh in cons consultation with the
Department that it' be much more
efficient to just have that run through
the general fund because we're talking a
very small dollar amount
um
and
uh and that's pretty much what the bill
does so the oh no sorry there's there's
more on page four um so the organic
processor processor Handler
certification fund that is a program
that the department not does not do
anymore and and that's being eliminated
uh and um then we and uh similarly the
the fees that are in 426 8A were fees
that were uh for a program that is no
longer um no longer being done uh and
then uh all the other deletions are for
434 uh which we've already discussed ex
well actually there are a couple in 612
which has to do with the dedicated fund
repeals
so that is the sum total of the bill it
is uh really a classic housekeeping bill
I think that will uh we have REM it will
remove a number of nonuseful statutes uh
and clarify what
remains and I'd be happy to take
questions thank you representa Bixby and
thank you for your work on this this is
um very very good to have um combined
some things uh taken out um things that
are Antiquated no longer used or
whatever but um could you talk a little
bit about um the Rel are you repealing a
section relative to Lumber
standards oh yes so um talk about the
lumber piece yes so uh so that is a that
is just a that's a mechanical process so
we're repealing it in 434 and uh and
instating it in 426 oh I got it see yeah
and the same thing with the apples and
The
Cider
okay all right any other questions
representative kraton is a simple
question and and I and I will say that
this was the most fun that I've ever had
at the House of Representatives it was
it was equivalent to watching paint dry
um but I I was wondering if you use this
on your campaign
speech as something no this is actually
a serious question because
people say you know what do you do and
the fact that it matters we got to rinse
a bunch of crazy stuff that you know
that that actually you know I I I just
want to applaud you for one bringing
this up two for doing the heavy lifting
on making it happen and three for
bringing me along because I I think you
know we did eliminate some trees that
are being cut every day and and I think
it's it's a lot of good work thank you
oh thank you and I I I think that um to
to follow through on representative
kraton's point I think that this is this
is I think the third study committee
I've done that deals with just doing a
deep dive on an existing chapter of Law
and figuring out what's current and what
needs to be fixed and uh I think that it
has
been um very valuable uh and I I think
this is a process we should I think it
makes sense to just pick one or two
chapters each term and go through them
and uh and update them uh so thank you
representative ktoa thank you madam
chair thank you representative for
taking my question or basically comment
uh having served with you on one of
these um committees the study committees
I think I agree with you that they're
extremely valuable and that this
committee should be doing a deep dive
and picking our essays to go through so
I I thank you again for this thank you M
representative
Howard thank you madam chair and I think
this also solves the um question about
where um representative Bixby gets his
uh um his uh encyclopedic knowledge of
our of our work here
yeah any other questions for
representative Bixby representative ktoa
thank you madam chair uh and thank you
representative uh do you have any ideas
of what rsay we should delve into next
um
I I haven't given that a lot of thought
but I'm happy to take suggestions I'm
also happy to hand over the work to of
chering it to someone
else
no all right thank you for introducing
the bill and answering questions and we
do have someone uh who would like to
speak on the bill who opposes the bill
Brendan
McQuade
okay
Mr qu McQuay do you have a copy of the
amendment at
all I do not oh okay would you like a
copy of the amendment I'll see if it
okay
does it change the part about
advertising does it change the part
about advertising did anyone notice that
advertising for apples yes it removes it
okay then You' you've done what I wanted
oh all right um yeah just to uh clue you
guys in I never thought I'd be before
the environment and agriculture
committee um the reason I'm here is for
the the New Hampshire press Association
because uh we noticed that it the
original version of The Bill had uh
stipulations regarding uh legal
advertising for apples um and I hate to
compare apples to uh political
advertising but the attorney general has
made me do it because last year he
arrested one of our Publishers for
publishing political advertising that
didn't meet the strict definition in the
law for political advertising arrested
her had her charge
and she was found guilty um so I would
caution you when you're looking at any
bills to make sure that if you put in
advertising you specify who's
responsible for that and that it's not
the guy who prints the flyers or Paints
the billboard or publishes the newspaper
um that it's actually the person who
should know their business and not the
person who's just publishing the
thing okay so I appreciate the amendment
and that's that's all I have open any
questions representative H Haskins thank
you madam chair once again very edifying
two days in a row new information coming
to four thank you very much who knew
huh okay thank you very much appreciate
it any other person like to speak on
this uh Bill HB
Amendment and Mr St did you get a copy
amendment because I know you're with New
Association okay all right
then any other questions or comments
anybody else want to speak on this bill
at
all okay I'm going to close out the
hearing for hb1
1628 thank you very much and it's uh
likely later this afternoon we will
sheet
HB 1628 let's
uh thank you okay so um and
I all right we are uh adjourn for lunch
o'clock
for
I
um so how how should I do this should I
go up there and introduce the bill or I
can introduce it from here you don't
have
yeah do that yeah because we're gonna
kill it yeah just that'd be fine if you
don't mind just makes it
easier
1578 we got
11 okay is is representative Davis out
there
okay two three four five
six eight nine 10 11
okay
right so okay
let's go with this here I'm going to
open up the hearing for HB
1578 and the prime sponsor said he was
not going to be here to introduce the
bill so representative Bixby has been so
kind as to take over that function all
right so um for the this representative
Bixby uh straford 13 do uh I am going to
open up HB
1578 uh and uh I don't know that I need
to do anything
[Laughter]
else oh this this bill is about
repealing the Organic certific
certification program
and um I think we're going to have a
discussion about this but um as I
pointed out this morning the program is
essentially uh dead now the bill we ex
that we heard this
morning uh covers almost everything that
1578 would do there is one line in 1578
that is absolutely necessary for the
current ongoing um uh operations for the
department and one line which which uh
uh authorize the department if they uh
with a as a May um under under a may may
have may do Organic certification under
under
USDA and um that um probably makes sense
to leave in place until the program is
entirely wound down okay so um that's
thank you for introducing the bill for
representative Bailey appreciate it and
so I will call uh Sean Jasper
Commissioner of Department of
go first of all I apologize put your
microphone on please I was looking at
the white light thought it was yeah I
should know better by now shouldn't I I
wanted to apologize to to the committee
for both side to both sides of of the
debate on um the funding and I
appreciate all the effort that that went
into that and um I should have informed
the committee beforehand and it was
really just the the day before that I
had come to the conclusion that if in
fact the bill went down there was no way
we could continue the
program and that was due to staffing
issues I'd always said that as long as
we had three people who um were
certified we could continue through 2024
and unfortunately that option was taken
away the bill had passed I'm still not
sure exactly what I would have done
because we still wouldn't have had
probably people in time but I should
have uh informed the committee that I
had made that decision and I have to
apologize to you things were moving
rather rapidly and it just it I didn't
even think of it at that time and when I
had a conversation with the with the
chairman I realized that I had certainly
made a an error which I regret I pride
myself on Communications and trying to
be transparent with what's going on and
I failed miserably and so I apologized
to the committee for that
failure um I was coming in support of
the
repeal uh understand exactly what uh
representative Bixby has said and um
that one line can be dealt with in in
the future uh but the the part of um
rulle making whatever happens needs to
stay in the bill because that actually
affects um other other rules that are
currently in place that don't have
anything to do with Organic but they do
reference that section so I'd be glad to
take any uh slings arrows or
questions thank you
commissioner thank thank you
commissioner I really appreciate um your
words and I appreciate your forthcoming
this um apology accepted thank you and
um thank you for coming and speaking on
this bill representative NAB thank you
madam chair thank you for taking my
question is there any benefit to leaving
this in statute even if it's dormant or
not currently funded I I don't think
there is I mean my preference would have
been that it just come out as of July
1st when our program will end
um but you know this is sort of like
what's going on with the the state meat
program that's on the books if you've
got something on statute people are
always saying why aren't you doing this
why aren't you doing this you know um
and and so it's more
of a an annoyance to leave things on the
books when they don't have any practical
effect and if the state was ever to
decide to to get back into that business
which I don't think there's going to be
the volume to to do that and just to let
you know that this last year the number
of
Acres um that we were certifying in the
ground um for production outside of
pasture land was less than 110
acres um and so that was a minuscule
number and it's not likely that we'll
ever be able to do anything that will um
be productive there are plenty out there
as you know who are doing it I it's a
sad day I am very sorry that it h had to
come to this I never you know there are
people out there who've said oh this was
your your plan since the day you came
into office and I say to people when I
became commissioner I didn't know a
thing about the organic program I didn't
know anything really about it until we
had to end the processing animal part of
it and my first words were no we're not
going to end that um because organic
farming is very important uh it's a very
important part of agriculture in New
Hampshire but for us to be a certifying
agent just doesn't make any
sense okay thank
you all right any other questions
represent Bixby this is somewhat
tangential but um I understand you've
been having some uh you've been opening
um communication lines with NOA New
Hampshire and you've been discussing
other ways that the department might be
able to support organic outside the the
certification program is that correct
thank you representative Bixby yes we we
started the discussions with NOA New
Hampshire on what we saw um happening
back in August of last year and those
have been very productive
discussions um and unfortunately I think
you know even as much as they were
looking at being a certifying agent or
or some sort of other Arrangement again
the scale of things didn't work for them
uh but what we've learned in this is
that people really want to have that
connection to the New Hampshire
Department of Agriculture one of the
things um that I think we can do um is
that we can expand our program in the
Seal of quality and probably just based
on their certification as organic really
just um allow them to use that seal on
any of their organic Pro programs it's
an underutilized program right now I
believe but I think we can can expand it
and I'd like to see that happen and as
soon as we get some breathing room we
will be doing that and um and looking at
that but um yeah that's one of the areas
that we can look at the other thing is
we will be able to provide advice to any
organic grower something we can't do now
although frankly Cooperative Extension
is in a better position to do that
because they're the Educators but we we
can be more helpful uh moving forward
certifier thank you any other questions
from the committee seeing none thank you
very much commission one more mad could
if you would like I could give you a
very brief update on the U uh crop
relief
program um the $8 million that was sure
sure it looks like there's not a lot of
people sure um just we did open that up
last Friday we already had um I think
two complete applications when we came
in on Monday and we had um three others
who had put an application and we're up
to um a much higher number now and we
may have as many of as five that we are
going to be able to go to governor and
council with uh next week so the word is
getting out there The Cooperative
Extension again did a great job and it's
an easy to uh navigate process and so
I'm looking forward to getting as much
money out there to people as possible
particularly since it looks like uh
we're already in Spring yeah um so I
know that Vineyards were hit pretty
badly weren't they not yes I mean they
they were I haven't talked to too many I
know flag hill and in Lee was and you
know every every sector of outdoor
agriculture was hit hard and every
sector of Agriculture uh outdoor
agriculture will be eligible for the
program this is this more about flooding
or Frost no it's it's it's all of the
above yeah so it's it's Frost it's
flooding drought uh well we didn't have
any drought condition we we didn't have
a drought yeah uh we certainly didn't
have any drought this year but we did
have a a number of freeze events and
then flooding and just generally very
wet conditions so we're going to look at
at everything I mean we've even had
Maple producers talking to us about poor
Maple crop they had particularly in
Southern New Hampshire last year because
it got so warm so quickly right uh which
unfortunately is the same situation
we're facing now and keeping our fingers
crossed at as warm as it is um we don't
get a couple of deep freezes certainly
we're by that first one that I think
killed all the peaches before they even
had an opportunity to come out now we're
just worried about are things going to
start to to Bud and then get a a killing
Frost don't jinx it well I I don't think
my words are going to have much impact
with with mother nature but I am I'm
certainly asking her not to hurt New
Hampshire agriculture again this year so
thank you okay we're confident we're GNA
get money out when it matters most all
right well thank you and thank you for
your efforts appreciate you coming today
Trumble
thank you Madame chairwoman and
committee members my name is David
Trumble I'm from Good Earth Farm in the
town of wear I uh opposed this bill for
a couple reasons uh before I get to that
I just wanted to say that as as part of
the record of the closing of the state's
organic program I think it should be
noted of great thanks to the Department
of Agriculture in particular the
inspectors who traveled throughout this
state to every corner over every bumpy
road to find the farmers they studied
the federal laws which are complex and
they made it understandable to the
farmers and treated them with a great
deal of
respect um so the reasons why I oppose
this bill first is I think it creates a
black hole that could be abused to the
detriment of the certified organic
farmers in the state even though the
state has stopped its certification
program this bill would eliminate the
requirements that first all crops
labeled as organic must meet the federal
standards and two that all crops labeled
as organic must be certified by a proper
agency I certainly don't expect the
Department of Agriculture to spend a lot
of time enforcing that but it should
remain on the books as a law if you're a
certified organic farmer in this state
and there are 130 at this point between
the New Hampshire program and those who
have had to go elsewhere if somebody
else is calling their produce organic
there's no recourse if you eliminate
this bill from the books and so there
should at least remain on the books a
law that says if you're calling your
produce or organic you have to meet the
federal rules and you have to be under a
uh organic program also would be
detrimental to any consumers who care
about this and it's worth remembering
when this discussion started last month
without a great deal of effort over a
thousand people signed the petition to
keep the program alive so the consumers
are concerned as well and I think it's
within the purview of the Department of
Agriculture the statute uh 52 something
that that sets up the department says
its number one purpose is to promote and
regulate AG agriculture in all of its
branches and also to regulate the
quality and grade of agricultural crops
so it wouldn't be out of the realm of
what the Department of Agriculture is
supposed to do just if this is one of
those rules that's come along and I
think it should remain the other reason
is I just wanted to tell a story about
the state certified organic farms and
their importance to agriculture I'll try
to use some numbers to tell that story
first of all I think that certified
organic farms account for almost 10% of
farm sales in the state you wouldn't get
that impression if you uh thought well
there's only 60 Farms with 100 acres but
actually this is from the usda's
agricultural census in 2022 New
Hampshire farms in total do $249 million
a business that's all the farms in the
state put together USDA also does a
separate organic survey and they
released this in December of 2022 it was
based on the 2021 numbers there were 93
certified organic farms that filled out
that survey and they did over $17
million in sales now NOA there's been a
lot of discussion this week with NOA
trying to help organic farmers find
alternative certifiers and so one of the
things that came through in this email
was that there's 128 certified organic
farms right now in the state 69 out of
state 59 inst state so 93 filled out
that survey but there's another 35 that
didn't fill out that USDA survey if you
just do ratios you would get up to $24
million in organic sales now maybe it's
not 24 million maybe it's only 21 or 22
million but it's pretty close to exactly
10% of the sales in the state and that's
just the certified organic farms if you
do less than $5,000 you don't bother
getting certified and there's a lot of
farmers in the state who just follow the
rules but don't get certified anyway so
that's about 10% don't forget as well
that under the new top program there's
20 Farms that are transitioning to
organic and they are talking about a
second wave of that program because
there's in so much interest so there'll
be more coming
another factor is that organic farms are
increasing production in that National
survey they ask over the next 5 years do
you plan to increase stay the same or
decrease only 2% said decrease and 2%
said go out of business 29% said
increase and the rest said stay the same
so in other words for everyone who's
thinking of reducing there's seven
Organic Farms who wanting to do more the
average age of a farmer in this country
is like 58 or something and not all of
them have a succession plan to somebody
in their family organic farmers want to
expand so not only will there be more of
them but the the ones that are in
business right now want to do more so
we're easily going to be well over 10%
of this state's um sales in agriculture
that's a significant amount another way
to look at it is like how productive are
we per acre do you think organic farms
are small farms or big farms it depends
on how you look at that but the USDA
census said that over half the farms in
this state do less than $5,000 worth of
business and 2third do less than $10,000
for a business so it's pretty much small
farms organic farms however under the
USDA survey only 24% do less than 10,000
so if you look at it like a pizza pie
Organic Farms I mean State Farms in
general almost 66% of them are less than
10,000 but only one in four organic
farms are these are serious Farms that
do a significant amount of business give
you one example in the testimony the
commissioner submitted last time his
example a median Farm after took out the
you know the the extra big farms which
would have skewed the numbers was that 3
acres of production $60,000 of gross how
much land would it take in cutting hay
to get to $60,000 if you get 160 bails
per acre maybe $8 a bail it would take
45 acres of land so that 3 Acre Farm
that you drive past you say well that's
a cute little farm a couple acres in a
greenhouse they generating more income
than somebody who's paying 45 acres of
land so we shouldn't just judge the
impact of farm Ms by how many acres they
have it's how much they're producing to
feed their people and also the last
thing is that certified organic farms
specialize in direct to Consumer sales
in that National survey 43% are direct
to Consumer 28% do csas 33% sell to
retail markets food hubs and
institutions we have to look at the
future of New Hampshire we don't have
the land base of States like New York
and Pennsylvania and Ohio and going
further we're kind of a hillside State
we only have so much good soil in the
state so direct to Consumer Farms that
are small farms direct to Consumer
that's the future of our state so I
think just to keep it that way is that
organic farms are important and I'm so
grateful to hear the commissioner say
that he's looking forward to ways to
find ways to support and promote organic
farming in the state but I urge you to
keep this bill on the books because you
just never know first of all we should
protect the farmers who are certified
organic so that nobody can claim they
are that if you get rid of this statute
there's no protection and who knows
maybe down the road things will change
and we'll find that 30 40 50% of our
sales are organic and then we will want
to get back into the certification
business you got the the law in the
books you don't have to go through all
rewriting it all over again it's not
costing you anything really to keep it
there so thank you very much for your
time appreciate any questions from the
committee seeing none thank you very
DRS you did not indicate support or
oppose or just not neither yeah
you Allan Wyman division of regulatory
Services New Hampshire Department of
Agriculture markets and food I uh also
the federally appointed executive
director of the Organics program as it
currently stands stands um I was asked
to come up and just provide some
clarification uh relative to what's
specific in this uh
Bill and to that I just want to point
out that the uh
definition and the use of the word
organic is 100% driven by federal law
and any law on the New Hampshire books
associated with it or making any
recommendation or specific there is no
legal New Hampshire has no legal bound
relative to the use of the word organic
or authority to go out and provide any
higher level enforcement associated with
that and
specifically
uh the USDA National organic program
regulates the term organic as a labeling
term for the product produced in
accordance with the organic foods
production act and NP regulations per
the ACT if a product is sold labeled or
represent it as organic then it must be
produced in accordance with the ACT and
NOP regulations from section
20512 there is a very specific uh
reference as well that enforcement of
the use of the word organic is overseen
and litigated by the NOP and not and
cannot be litigated by the state and
there is an actual website for the
complaint and enforcement of the use of
the inappropriate use of the word
organic uh so it had been my
recommendation initially to take
references to the use of the word
organic enforcement of the use of the
word organic or labeling such as in 426
6A relative to the use of the word
organic out of our rsas because we have
actual no the state has no legal
Authority and I'm telling you that as a
federal agent executive director of the
NLP program so I mean that's that's it
committee okay
representative Bixby I'd just like to
make a note for the committee which is
that um the bill that we heard this
morning uh included the the removal of
those as per director Wyman's um
recommendation so uh so that that that
is already we've already acted on
that
right well we haven't exec that we
haven't exec that bill we heard it we've
already heard it yeah yeah okay all
right anyone else wish to speak on this
bill seeing none I'm going to close the
hearing
for what's the number again
HB 1578 I'm closing the hearing for that
I need the blue
sheet and uh let's see what there's
anything
online
see nothing online nothing there and
s78 we had um three in support and 95
um I suppose after we hear the next two
bills we can exec out um this bill that
we just heard and the two that we heard
this morning yeah um if that would be
okay with the committee absolutely all
right um so we're going to proceed with
HB opening the hearing for HB
1529 relative to the use of
unpasteurized
eggs and uh let's see that's
1529 and the sponsor of the bill is
representative
Sullivan here to introduce the bill yeah
all
right thank you welcome to environment
and agriculture yeah thanks for having
me it's great um so yeah so this is
pretty simple maybe somebody from Health
and Human Services can explain that
somebody suggested this might be in
rules and maybe something that doesn't
need to be addressed but this is pretty
simple basically what happened was
there's a constituent of mine who own
ice cream store she would like she likes
to work on using everything as local as
possible she so she can list the sources
of all of her ingredients up on the up
on her board when you walk into her her
restaurant and when she's making ice
cream she is required to use pasteurized
eggs as an input even though the process
of making ice cream it pasteurizes in
the machine and so she asked me if there
was something we could do about it and
it was at the very end of the bill
filing session so I didn't have a lot of
time to research what the rules were and
stuff like that because I think I was up
against like an hour or two before
filing deadlines uh closed so uh the
goal of this is is basically if you have
uh a process that includes pasturization
later in the process you can use an
unpasturized
egg right now she's getting eggs that
are pre- pasturized they come from like
Cisco or wherever and she would like to
just go to the local farms in my
community to get eggs to make her ice
cream so that's the bill or the idea of
the
committee representative Howard thank
you madam chair and do you know the
process that use to pasteurize eggs um I
I I have chickens and if I give my eggs
away I I just wash them with soap and
water is it is it more than
that um I think it involves the
pasteurizing involves heating I believe
and so when she makes the I don't know
the right word is the base or the batter
I don't know what you call it for making
ice cream but when she makes that she
puts into the ice cream machine and it
gets heated up for an extended period of
time and so
I would think that that would count
because it's it's very hot it's like
cooking
essentially um May it maybe maybe
there's somebody who knows more than me
on this um but that I I believe
pasteurizing is is involved a heating
it's not just cleaning it's heating of
things represent Bixby okay so um I'm
gonna kind of as ask this as a kind of
leading question so uh if you're using
eggs and ice cream you're typically
that's typically called the custard
based ice cream and the
so typically one would make the custard
and then be before which is a heating
process before uh the freezing process
where you then turn it into ice cream uh
and is that is that basically what she's
doing uh she does heat it and then the
way it works is I did make the ice cream
there for one period of time so I do
know a little bit about it but yeah we
would we we would blend everything into
thing we pour it into the machine it
would heat for a while and then you drop
it into the next thing to to chill it
and then you pour it out of that you put
in the tubs you freeze
it representative
Murray thank you madam chair I think the
process that you're referring to is
called tempering when you're bringing
the batter or what have you up to
temperature you're cooking the mixture
and you're heating that um and then um
so there is a there is a cooking process
process to the eggs is is what you're I
think getting at
yes okay so a according to statute the
way statute is now is she prohibited
from producing this
product she's prohibited from using
local eggs because there's no local egg
that is pre pasteurized so the eggs as
an input into the batter or the the base
are not p are pastu are required to be
pasteurized and she can't find a New
Hampshire or a local based source of um
pasteurized eggs so she's buying them
from like a food supplier everything
else she where did she get that
information that she needed pasteurized
eggs uh when they were giving her her
food
license
okay all right represent Bixby okay so
this might be more of a question for um
the folks from food Pro Protective
Services but uh
when I looked in statute I I basically
did a search on eggs and I didn't find
anything in statute on eggs uh so my
guesses it might be in rules yeah okay
that's possible and and so I I mean
maybe it could be addressed in rules or
maybe this will take care of that but uh
that is the intention of this and like I
said when I was introducing the
bill this was a very late request that
she came to me with um like I said I
think it was whatever that Friday is the
last day we could file bills and it was
in the afternoon so I didn't have a lot
of time so I yes I was like I'll I'll
explain it to them and get it out I just
didn't have time to like actually do the
the research process that we that I did
for other bills that I
introduced any other questions from the
committee thank you for introducing the
bill and um I now call Colleen Smith
from DHHS to come and
speak
good
afternoon good afternoon Madam chair and
members of the committee thank you for
allowing us to speak on House Bill 1529
relative to egg pasteurization and I
actually have Chuck matap who supervises
our Dairy program he's actually here to
testify in the next bill but but he also
is an expert on on ice cream production
so he would definitely be able to add to
this conversation okay so um
what the bill is proposing that
the unpasturized eggs are already
allowed to be used at retail uh either
at a restaurant or a retail food store
if they are offered in an undercooked
form there has to be a menu disclosure
and and a warning that consuming uh raw
or undercooked eggs could lead to food
born illness so there might be some
confusion with what this particular
person was looking to do um I can tell
you that when you call something
pasteurized it doesn't necessarily it
there is a temperature involved but it's
also equipment that's involved and that
that that term pasteurization it means
that it's it's conducted by an actual
tested pasteurizer and Mr Med can also
add add Clarity if there are specific
questions regarding that
process representative Marie thank you
madam chair and thank you for taking my
question so with regard to the is there
anything stated in rules or in statute
otherwise because we have done some you
know deep diving a little bit to take a
look at the concept of quote the use of
unpasteurized eggs and we couldn't find
anything in statute so could you
elaborate on if there is anything in
rules that would have this would could
potentially lead to this conclusion So
within our our rules we have adopted the
2017 Federal food code and so that would
would require any raw eggs used um that
were not going that weren't presented as
being in an undercooked or raw form as
being cooked to 165 um if you're using
an egg product like a liquid egg a
commercial liquid egg product that has
to be that has to be from a pasteurized
Source from a food processing plant in a
pasteurized from a pasteurized Source
follow up you thank you and when you're
talking about a liquid product you're
talking about sometimes those things
that come in the boxes that have already
been cracked act they're um in a in a
container whether it's whites or whites
and yolks together is that correct
correct something that you would buy
from a of a commercial processor of of
eggs already in a liquid form okay thank
you so so how do they how do they
pasturize it with actually without
egg so um I guess to try to answer that
question I'll also reference it back to
um how the bill was introduced so we
currently
already allow raw eggs to be part of an
ingredient to be used to make ice cream
as long as that ice cream mix is going
to be pasteurized um I have this
question um asked probably three or four
times a year that we get inquiries I
don't know that they all move forward
with it but it is currently allowed with
um within our Dairy program which
licenses the wholesale operations we do
not in the dairy program we do not
licensed like a restaurant making it and
only serving it to their immediate
customer that would fall back to the
retail food program and when you
pasteurize the mix you're bringing it up
to a minimum of 100 um and usually it's
150 and you're going to hold it there
for 30 minutes and that will not cook
the egg to the point where it's you're
going to have egg Parts in it it's just
going to be like a milkshake type of
consistency that you then run through
your batch freezer that turns it into
what you're used to seeing as ice
cream okay um yes uh represent
Murray thank you madam chair so when
we're talking about prep pasteurized
eggs are we talking about a like a a
radiated like pre- pasteurized so that
they're still liquid they're not in this
a milkshake form or what have you is
there is there any process like that
where the eggs are coming shelled or in
the liquid form where they are
pasteurized in that
way so there are spec there are specific
processes that can pasteurize an inshell
egg um they're we they're very expensive
so they're not very common in the
marketplace the time often time that you
would find them is um usually serving a
highly susceptible population like in a
a hospital nursing home scenario but
there is technology that can actually
pasturize an inshell inshell egg and
they're they have a little pee on the
outside of them but as I said we don't
really see those um in retail
establishments because they are very
costly represent Bixby okay so uh just
for clarity in terms of the problem that
brought this bill forward would uh
representative Sullivan's uh constient
constituent already be um okay under the
uh based on the fact that she's uh the
machine she's using to make her ice
cream raises the custard to temperature
for a period and then before it's then
chilled and
Frozen so as long as she was only
offering it through her retail
establishment so if she wanted to
package it and sell it to other
businesses that's when she would have to
have a fully pasteurized
product okay so uh and followup please
followup yeah uh so um so the so the
fully so
um would the would the fully pasteurized
product have to be a product that is you
know starting with pasteurized eggs or
would could it could she use the uh the
um Regular you the the real
EGS and then incl put those into the mix
and then pasteurize the mix uh and then
produce the ice cream from that
pasteurized mix the answer would be yes
she would be allowed to go down and get
her Source her eggs locally she could
also be starting out with raw milk um
because this mixture as we're talking
about is going to undergo the
pasteurization step so uh typically in a
scenario like this the questions that I
get asked is this person would like to
start out with their own raw milk
typically it's also using their own raw
eggs from their own Farm um and then
they put everything together with the
sugars or whatever else their base mix
for their ice cream is is looking to
have in it some use stabilizer some
don't want to they pasteurize that in as
Colleen said the pasteurization
equipment that we would look for and
then they turn it into ice cream and
sell it um wholesale and Retail
typically at that point okay uh followup
so the main difference between uh being
able to do it retail and doing it
wholesale is that you need to have uh
equipment that was certified as U
pasteurizing equipment and but beyond
that as long as the steps are are made
to heat it to the appropriate
temperature for the appropriate time uh
it would be Avail wholesale retail would
be fine uh but the you need special
equipment for wholesale is that correct
that is how I understand it sir yes
thank a representative Katon and then
represent Murray okay just just to make
sure I'm clear because I'm done with
this this bill is not necessary because
she can already already do
it that is how I would understand it yes
okay and is it can I follow follow up
sure yeah and can you give your number
to him so that he can call you and or
she can call you and square it away is
that possible that's 100% possible thank
you sir appreciate thank you
representative
Murray thank you madam chair and and and
to the member's Point um with regard to
whether or not I there might be a
circumstance in I don't know the
business's circumstance of whether or
not they're seeking
wholesale and if that's the case um it's
possible that their machine already does
this and they're just
not communicating that effectively
because there are machines out there
that do that process heat it for the
appropriate amount of time and then cool
it is that correct am I understanding
that correct that is correct the caveat
that I will throw out there just for
full disclosure is a lot of them that
are advertised that are more homebased
would not meet our rules for the
pasteurizer so I don't want to leave the
committee with an understanding that
just because a homebased unit touts that
it Cooks it that it would meet the
regulations that we have in place um but
there are a lot of small pasteurizers
out there the smallest that I have
personally tested was a two gallon stove
top unit that met the rules and
regulations so they go down as low as
two gallons and I've seen 2,000 gallon
on so I think you know it runs
again do you know how much those cost at
all um the very small ones no the
midsize ones that are very popular with
our goat Farmers um probably are running
above 10,000 the tabletop ones I suspect
are a whole lot less because they just
don't have um as much built into them
but they the manufacturer knew what the
rules were for across the 50 states that
they want to sell them in and so they
built it with that in
mind okay thank
you no it's just I'm just you know for
the farmer what it would cost them I
don't know representative ger you have a
question I do thank you madam chair and
this is more for my edification as
supposed to anything else and because
I'm curious about the language of the
bill which it sounds like is not
necessary anyway but with reference to
the difference between resale and
wholesale um sales uh the bill refers to
a food service
establishment or retail food store right
and so those two categories are separate
from wholesale
correct I I just wanted to clarify
because we were talking about that
differ so in this case this bill which
would be particular to if it's an
establishment or retail sale it's not
necessary if wholesale was involved that
wouldn't be covered covered by this bill
anyway correct we do have just for
clarification again we do have multiple
retail restaurants that make their ice
cream that originally started out just
for their customers and so many people
told them how good it was that they now
wholesale it to other places so we have
dairy licenses issued to retail
restaurants if you will because they
also wholesale their product so I just
want to make sure that that it can be in
the same physical establishment I
appreciate that thank you you any other
questions from the
committee thank you very much we
appreciate you educating us on a lot of
the points of this and uh anyone else
bill no samples no ice cream
samples G giz giz okay I'm going to
close out
HB
somewhere uh yeah so we have two in
support online we have two in support
forthcoming we can probably exec this
bill too this afternoon huh that would
be
great super
duper okay and then we've got uh one pro
Sullivan just so you know because he had
J Sullivan yeah okay thank you
representative
Sullivan okay uh so we've got a little
bit of a break between now and two
o'clock when is when is our next hearing
we could do some uh yeah if you wanna if
you want to exec any bills in between
now and then get it done are we good
okay
got
Davis representative Davis
Davis we need you we're we're gonna EXA
both Okay Okay so we've got um HB
1578 which is the relative to organic
food certification and labeling which is
what we heard at one o'clock yeah
um who would like to make the motion on
that and ultimately write the uh
committee
report oh sure oh Peter you're you're
you're such a trooper give one to the
team I gotta open up first of all I got
to open up the exec session for hb1
1578 uh do I hear a
motion represent Biby yes I move that we
I move that uh HB 1578 be an expedient
to legislate representative kraton you
have a second yes ma'am second okay uh
any discussion on that
bill seeing none uh on representative
lety first of I'm sorry I didn't hear
representative Bixby is it itl itl okay
so um I I thought um the um Mr Trumble
was very passionate about what he said
and I was wondering if there was any way
that we could amend the bill to be able
to meet his requirements which was uh
the the request to keep the standards
for Organics or was that the whole issue
with the definition of Organics that we
can't have it in statute anyway so so
okay so so then disregard my comment
okay um so represent
n thank you madam chair I did think
there was another piece beforehand that
we said we were going to keep in there
and um oh okay so um there was language
that and I think it was you
representative Bixby that mentioned okay
so so um this would be an issue only if
we passed the
bill okay so there oh okay sorry I am a
little okay so there so just a got it
quick clarification there are a number
of things that HB
1578 uh was repealing many of them were
were also repealed by uh 1628 which we
heard this morning
and the only one the only things that
were not repealed by
1678 or 15 1628 were the um
authorization for uh the department to
have a certification program and the
authorization for the Department to do
any rule Mak making in chapter 5
426 and the uh Ru making is
so uh probably the most important reason
to itl HB 1578 is because it would
redundant it would well it would it's
well yes it's redundant but the worst
thing about it is that it repeals rule
making for the entire
chapter and we don't want to get rid of
the entire chapter or hamstring the
department on
making thank
you
okay do I hear the clerk call the rooll
please so the motion is itl on HB
1578 representative kraton hi
representative coma yes representative
Davis yes representative Kenny yes
representative Bixby yes representative
Duty yes representative Murray yes
represent Jama yes representative H
Haskins I representative Howard yes
yes 12 Z motion passes shall we put it
on consent yes
yes
okay we we have a few minutes if you
want to um exec
just exact another one so we've got um
uh HB
1463 uh well first of all let me close
the uh exec for hb1 1578 open up the
exec session for HB
1463 establishing a committee to study
the effects of laws relative to the
production of beef pork and poultry do I
hear motion representative ktoa thank
you madam chair I'd like to make motion
of OTP
I hear a second representative Bixby I
second that would you like to speak to
your motion representative
ktoa uh thank you madam chair I just
think that this uh study committee would
be worthwhile it will help uh put into
hopefully put into place under one
section where people in agriculture
especially the meat farmers can go to to
understand the actual rules and
laws any any other comment on this bill
represent Bixby
um I look forward to seeing uh
one duly
noted seeing no other conversation on
this call ask the clerk to call the
rooll on hb1 1463 thank you madam chair
the motion is OTP on hb1 1463
representative kraton hi representative
coma yes representative Davis yes
representative Kenny yes yes represent
Bixby yes represent Duty yes represent
Murray yes represent Jama yes
represented H Haskins I representative
Howard yes representative NAB Madam
chair yes motion passes 120 shall It Go
on consent yes
please okay I will close out the exact
session for HB
um we can do one more if you have you
all want go for it okay I open up the
exec session for HB
16 uh 28 relative to regulatory
Authority for apples Co grading potatoes
cider milk and lumber do I hear a motion
oh wait a minute no first you have to do
yeah adoption of the amendment oh oh
first we have to do an adoption
Amendment um do I hear a motion on the
amendment yes I I move that we adopt uh
HB oops where's my 202 4956 a um uh HPS
2628 with Amendment uh what she just
said no what is the amendment is what
0956 okay do I hear a second to that
I'll second
that
all right uh would you like to speak to
your motion I think we discussed this
pretty thoroughly this morning um so I
think we'll just go ahead and um do it
okay uh so have the clerk call the role
on the
amendment so this is to adopt Amendment
56h uh representative
kraton I represent ktoa yes
representative Davis yes representative
Kenny yes represent Bixby yes represent
Duty yes represent Murray yes represent
Jam yes represent H Haskins I represent
Howard yes represent NAB yes Madam chair
Yes 120 motion passes okay do I hear a
motion for otpa represent I move um otpa
on HB 1628 with
Amendment
um
second any
discussion I think we're good to go good
to go okay um I ask clerk to call the
role
please conf
okay
second
good okay so the motion is otpa on HB
1628 representative kraton I
representative ktoa yes representative
Davis yes representative Kenny yes
representative Bixby yes representative
Duty yes representative Murray yes
representative Jam yes represent H
Haskins I represent Howard yes represent
NAB yes Madam chair Yes 120 shall go on
consent
yes okay I'm going to close out the exec
on hb1
1628 and we'll might might as well just
do the one more
um um unless you want to wait and do the
hearing first
just it's it's past two so let's let's
do the hearing and um we'll we'll finish
up with the rest so I'm going to open up
the hearing for HB 1574 removing
regulations on the direct sale of raw
milk to
Consumers and let's see
1574 representative Granger was the
sponsor of this
Bill and as I look around the room there
he is nowhere to be
seen so um I guess I can introduce the
bill
um just basically uh what this bill does
is it eliminates the 20 gallon raw milk
um uh
cap uh and it also uh eliminates the uh
six fluid ounce restriction on frozen
yogurt produced and sold in under the
statute and that's all I know about
this so um I do have some pink cards for
folks who would like to speak on of
opposition of this bill so I invite um
uh Rob Johnson from Farm Bureau to come
and
speak
thank you madam chair members of the
committee good afternoon for the record
Rob Johnson representing the F Bureau as
a federation's policy director and we
are in in strong opposition to House
Bill
1574 as you may imagine we have members
on both sides of the issue uh on this
but our uh our commercial Dairy Farmers
they have made uh huge investments in
their operations it's their life work
and they are very concerned with any
type of negative publicity coming from a
a uh a product that they spent their
life's work selling product from another
farmer that uh causes problems uh any
type of health
issues
and I want to point out
that in lines uh three and four uh that
would strike the the uh sales limit of
20 gallons if I'm remembering correctly
I think it was back in
2012 where we supported an increase in
that limit from 5 to 20 gallons thinking
it'd be a reasonable compromise uh that
that number if you to give you an idea
of how many how much 20 gallons is
it's it's probably it's the production
of I would say two very high producing
cows depending on breed to uh to uh May
four maybe five you know grade uh uh
cows so we we think that that leaves uh
a fair uh um a fair fair number Fair
area for somebody who who wants to uh
sell directly to a knowing uh consumer
and then I want to point out the lines
eight and nine that language that is
struck that language became effective
two years ago in in 2022 and as the
chair knows there was a lot of work by a
number of groups coming to compromise an
agreement there to enable the the sale
of raw milk ice cream and frozen yogurt
and we we uh we don't see a need for any
increase and would ask the committee
again to to uh find this bill itl I I
just want to add and I know you'll hear
more from from the the the the
department on on their concerns but um
at Farm Bureau we also have SE we've
seen both sides of the issue and mean
and I say this and that on the insurance
side uh we uh uh whole we used to own an
insurance company and we a few years
back when we were we were owners we had
an issue where we had a um a issue with
with uh consumers uh insured uh
consuming uh raw milk in in and they and
they experienced the maybe the worst
case scenario where they ended up on
dialysis and it was a huge expense for
for our agency huge um and I'll just
just kind of want to uh mention that and
uh as always appreciate your time and
attention thank you uh any questions
from the committee representative ktoa
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question uh would you think a
modest increase to say 30 gallons would
be
okay we haven't discussed that I I do
think our our commercial folks would
have some concerns I think they think 5
to 20 I know was we had a lot of
discussion at the time I think we're
we're comfortable with where the the
statue is that
now yeah I am I just I touched base with
Jill fidela who owns The Little Red Hen
Farms um because she was involved in the
conversations and I'd let her know about
this particular bill as well and she
indicated to me that you know she she
wouldn't mind and then she was in that
in those conversations that we had when
we came to these this compromised
language uh that's in statute now um
that she wouldn't mind that it if it was
raised to 30 gallons and and she would
welcome um any kind of increase in the
Frozen and yogurt uh ice cream as well
to to be a little bit more than just the
six fluid ounces because she's finding
that the smaller cups are more difficult
to deal with and it would have be nice
to have a little bit more that they
could put in a package so I'm just going
to put that out there in terms of um I I
don't want to I don't want to say formal
testimony but just in her uh
conversation with me about it and um we
can can probably discuss this with the
uh DHHS folks as well but I'm just
putting that out there for you yeah
thank you madam sh like I said we
haven't discussed it internally I think
our our Farmers would have concerns and
if you did something like that we would
ask you not to do it through amending
this that new uh new bill be introduced
and then we can have the discussion
right right okay gotcha thank you any
other
questions no seeing none thanks again
thank you and I call Colleen Smith
DHHS good afternoon again again for the
record my name is Colleen Smith I'm with
the Department of Health and Human
Services food protection section and I
have with me Mr Chuck mataf he
supervises our Dairy program thank you
madam chair and members of the committee
for allowing us to speak on in
opposition to House Bill
1574 thank you I have written testimony
which is being circulated but I will try
to um summarize some of our major
concerns raw milk has is has higher risk
for foodborn illness eoli cryptosis
seminol Aleria Brussel these are some of
the microorganisms that have been
associated with raw milk and raw milk
outbreaks and unfortunately we we went
through a a a major investigation of a
raw milk outbreak in 2021 where 50
people were sickened with cample actor
um across three states and even a few
pets um had consumed the the raw milk um
we have we have seen increases in food
born illness associated with raw milk
and this is also a TR with other states
that have that allow raw milk or raw
milk products to be to be produced so we
certainly have concerns about expansion
for those reasons um and also as Mr
Johnson pointed out is we also are
protecting the reputation of our dairy
industry and our Dairy Farmers and and
any outbreaks asso associated with milk
is very damaging to the industry as a
whole um we also have concerns about
removing that size limit that for the
ice cream or frozen dessert product as
this was put into place because these
small manufacturers don't have
commercial Blast chillers freezers to be
able to effectively cool uh cool the
product quickly um to R minimize that
risk for bacteria to that may be present
in that raw milk product to grow that
was one of the in working in crafting
that compromise to allow fro frozen
desserts and Frozen ice cream to be sold
that size limitation was very very very
important for those that were involved
so we would have definitely have
concerns about removing that um and and
finally the department is also concerned
that this not only does this remove the
limit but it also allows for any type of
raw milk product to be produced and
queso fresco type cheeses those are soft
cheeses those are particularly
vulnerable to outbreaks of leria that
those would be allowed to be made in
this instance so we we also have
concerns about about removing the limits
to the types of products that can be
made with raw milk and and as we have
mentioned before while there are
labeling requirements um the we have
very difficulty with enforcing those
because the they're they're unlicensed
they're unregulated for the most part by
our department we we can we react to
complaints of course but as far as
regular inspection we we don't know that
the if that's being done on a regular
basis we don't know the the universe of
raw milk producers because there's no
registration there's no licensing so we
um we have difficulty enforcing the
statute and the limits it's very much in
honor System as it is now 20 gallons a
day is allowed um we can't tell you if
maybe there's somebody making 25 it it's
it's very much an honor System with
those that are operating under the
licensing and exemption uh we are happy
to answer any questions that you may
have for us thank you representative
ktoa thank you madam chair and thank you
for being here and for taking my
question
um it is my understanding and maybe you
could clarify that one of the issues
with increasing the size of the ice
cream container is that it would be
possible for something to remove that
container eat some of it then refreeze
it and the bacteria still stays in there
and grows even in the freezer is is that
correct yes yes that was also one of the
reasons Not only was the the ability of
a smaller producer to cool the original
manufactured product but also that
having a larger gallon siiz container if
you will that might be taken out of a
refrigerator or ref freezer and served
and then put back in thought that there
could be opportunities for bacteria to
grow in that instance representa come to
our followup thank you madam chair and
thank you again for taking my question
um you said there was an outbreak in
2020 could you speak to what the cause
of that outbreak was so the the
determination that it would it was caor
bacteria that was in that instance and
we also want to point out is that that
that the illnesses could have been much
greater in that instance if it wasn't a
very quick response by that particular
Farm to not only notify the department
of what was happening but also this
particular farmer kept a customer log
and was able to reach out to the
specific people that they had
distributed the milk product to so that
also was um a very a situation that
could have been a lot worse if it wasn't
for that quick reaction of that farmer
another followup thank you madam chair I
I guess my question is is what caused
the
Campo the the illness to happen do you
know so so you you want to take this one
I don't know that we will know
definitively
um but the isolation of that was came
from a single sample that we took from
the farm that came from a single animal
um that the farmer had said wasn't
feeling well prior um so it's possible
that that is the that the animal was
sick and it shed into the milk um but
it's it's a tough one to pick up and so
it may not have been only from that
individual cow U but we did test I don't
remember the number of samples and the
lab picked up the campy in that one at
least in that one sample on that
outbreak represent
viby so um a number of years ago when we
were discussing some other variation on
uh on raw milk uh bills uh one of the
things that uh you and and I think the
your predecessor as director pointed out
was that uh one of the pieces of logic
with the small amount that's available
small um small allowance is that by
keeping it small it constrains the
possible uh out the the possible reach
of an outbreak is that something that um
you could you elaborate a little bit on
that know certainly that um the the
wider distribution there there is more
um Poss possibility of of a greater um
outbreak in the instance that um the
campor outbreak that we just talked
about that farm had do you recall the
exact number of cows that they were
milking that farm was licensed with us
as a raw milk producer and I believe it
was milking maybe in the neighborhood of
15 to 20 cows so for raw milk producer
it was of a fairly decent size for what
we see in New Hampshire because your
bigger Farms are going to be the
commercial ones that you would see
shipping milk so but he was milking
probably 15 to 20 cows represented Bixby
yeah and just for
clarification uh that farm and um and
brookford farm would be another one that
people might be familiar with uh are
licensed which means they have an
inspection routine and that's not this
that wouldn't be the story that wouldn't
be the case with the Farms that this
bill is addressing that is correct this
bill would El would exempt them from
license share and then exempt from
license share we don't do the
inspections on those because we don't
know who they are okay so followup
followup so that could in fact make it
more difficult to do the the rapid
response that you did when the farm and
Rollinsford had the
problem I would say yes we would have to
hear about it from you know once we
heard about it we would start
investigating but we would not
necessarily have a relationship or know
who they are in this case here as
Colleen pointed out this farmer because
we had that working relationship reached
out to us over the weekend to let us
know what he thought was happening so
that we had a very quick by Monday
morning we were already rolling with
what we were going to do versus trying
to get up to speed because we had that
working relationship where we did
inspections we did samples and
whatnot thank you okay any other
questions from the the
committee NOP representative Howard
thank you madam chair um is uh keeping a
a customer list um routine practice or
or recommended practice at at these um
raw milk
farms um it's probably recommended I
would say most of the ones that I've had
contact with Do It um because they want
to be able to reach out to them if
something new is coming up maybe not so
much for thinking about an illness but
more thinking about if they offer a new
product or just they a lot of them will
have like a monthly newsletter that they
might want to send out so they do tend
to keep a a lot of them I'm not going to
say all of them by any stretch but a lot
of them do keep a customer list some of
them will even as you go and pick up
your product because a lot of it is
self-service so they might not be
Manning a store like you would expect
and the they asked the customer to write
down you know 24 datee 24 I I bought two
gallons of raw milk and paid the $6 or
what what not so they track it that way
um whether they capture everybody or not
is I'm not sure um the other thing I'd
like to say is I did not coordinate this
with Rob but in case I was asked about
20 gallons and how many cows that might
be my number was four to five cows so we
were very close on that um Just for
information that limit does not is not
species specific so that would be about
a farm with 30 goats and about a farm
with 80 sheep if you were staying within
that 20 gallon limit and we do have
sheep and goat farms that obviously are
licensed and others that are not within
the
state okay so four to five if two 20
gallons is four to five cows four to
five depending on breed and depending on
how you feed them right and or 30 goats
approximately 30 goats uh or
approximately 80 sheep 80 sheep correct
to get to the same 20
gallons that's a lot
yeah right okay thank you right
um all right any other questions for
DHHS seeing none thank you very much for
coming in educating
us and we need the blue sheet anybody
else want to speak on this see
uh it's seven and
support no
online seven in support and three
opposed online and then on the blue
sheet we have one
against and I'm going to close out the
okay
um I want to entertain the idea of
executing um hb1
1529 which we just heard before relative
to the use of unpasteurized eggs because
it seemed a little clear to me that that
legislation um wasn't necessary I would
agree to that would you agree to that I
mean I have an ex for that do you if you
give me a minute I will go again okay
we'll give you a minute does anybody
um else have any issue
with the egg
Bill are we interested in the raw milk
bill at all we want to talk about that
with the Fuller committee I think I
think we might have a couple of members
who might have might want to weigh in
who aren't here I mean sure I I have a
pretty strong feel where I want to go
with it but yeah but but I think but I
think that that in terms of maintaining
sort of a a balance of input on the
committee I think we should okay wait
until some other members who might have
different ideas no
worries did we have basically the same
bill last year wasn't it the same I
remember the the the serving size for
yogurt okay so ice cre the same
basically what we had last year was the
bill that put this into put it into
statute the way it is now and that bill
took three terms to get in
place so I have absolutely no desire to
mess with it because it took long enough
to get it in
place
yeah yeah not two years ago last two
because I remember the discussion about
gallons of raw milk oh there may oh yeah
May
was that was road because we had a
former I believe maybe chair of this
committee a member of this committee who
had come in and he was originally gonna
speak in favor of it and then he came up
and said having listened to testimony oh
yeah yeah yeah exactly that was funny
because he said I was gonna testify in
favor they getting for and and I have
getting
16 not T I think he probably hadn't read
it
carefully
just wait no we're doing um 1529 1529
bill this because I think I think rep
would be irritated if we did this
well if if someone wants to make motion
I'll just write everything in the back
for now we'll wait for the paper it's
fine it's fine I've done it
before okay um I think he something from
here represent now thank you I would
motion do would you like to speak to In
Motion representative
NAB um I think we heard that this bill
was unnecessary that it was um maybe a
bit of a misunderstanding that the
constituent believed that they could not
use unpasteurized
eggs okay that's all any other uh
comments from the
Committee hearing none I'd like the U
clerk to call the role then thank you
you madam the motion is itl on HB 1529
representative kraton I representative K
yes representative Davis yes represent
Kenny yes represent Bixby yes represent
sopie Duty yes represent Murray yes
represent Jam yes represent H Haskins I
represent Howard represent NAB yes Madam
chair yes 12 Z shall It Go on consent
yes
um we've had we've had a long two days
together and uh I think uh we are done
for today and uh I guess we will see
each other tomorrow in session
but next Wednesday we are not going to
be meeting on Tuesday because it's um
town meeting
day and so we are going to have our um
meeting on Wednesday we are going to
exec some bills in the
morning um I'm going to move some things
around probably and we've got three more
bills to
hear um we are going to have a work
session on those bills after we hear
them so that we can come back on March
19th and exec everything that we have
left so we're going to be done on the
19th yay team you guys have done amazing
job and then we'll see what the Senate
sends us yes um I do know that
representative kraton has an
announcement for a field trip that he's
planned in April yes ma'am um on the 5th
of April we have coordinated with um
Waste Management to go on a field trip
and they're going to um lay it out Soup
To Nuts what they do what Their concerns
are and take us all over they've got a
bus laid on so we get there to waste
management and I'll send out details
later once we arrive they put us on a
bus and they'll take us all over so that
we can see the Lee Fields we can see the
the actual double layer um uh protection
we can see the the monitoring Wells we
can see the lee8 processing facilities
we can see the input and talk to them
about where it's coming from and how
they separate it out and uh so I'm I'm
excited it's going to be a great day and
they all they're all set to host us and
Dees and we've been cleared for mileage
and we have been cleared for mileage I
will send out the form for mileage when
I send out the details on the trip that
what's
that boots mck boots yeah no yeah no
dress
that thank you for putting that together
yeah no no excited it's a team effort I
also know at some point we are going to
have a breakfast with Farm Bureau uh
would you like to give us some
that I don't have anything planned for
April 16 but I imagine we may have uh we
may have um meetings for the Senate
bills is that
when
and you'll send out something to our
committee formal
invitation okay
wonderful thank you now I do have one
other
thing one other announcement I have one
other announcement this is not committee
related but it is veteran related um the
ad General General m litis is coming on
the 2nd of April at
lunch uh also um Colonel Monroe who is
the chief of army um recruitment in New
England she's coming to talk to us about
Veterans Affairs and and things that we
can do to help and in several different
specific ways but also just to touch
base on some of their concerns
some of the discussion I mean I only
served for 34 years so I don't know a
lot but some of the discussion on the
house was not factually based and so my
idea is to bring in the folks that
actually know these things so we can
have an open discussion it'll be who
they who are they going to be speaking
with in the so the invitation is out to
the whole house and what's the date
again on the second of April at
noon and uh so we're inviting everyone
we just got to nail down the room it'll
be somewhere here in the lob and um it
it's just an open discussion with some
folks that are really doing a whole lot
of work for us and I think we did them
some disservice a couple weeks ago and
so we're going to give them I just want
to open the dialogue so that we know
what they're doing and how we can help
that's that's the biggest thing all
right so with that I adjourn the meeting
our meetings till next week we'll see
you have uh have a good rest of the week
tomorrow